fiscal
good morning everybody i hope everybody
got some rest
from last night
um
the announcement for this meeting
started with house bill 1237 but i'm
going to change the order we're going to
start with house bill 12
due to a time commitment
and the prime sponsor 1288 wasn't able
to be with us last week
therefore she
uh
representative mcguire
is here this morning representative
yes uh thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire
allen's town epsom in pittsfield and
house bill 1288 cleaned started just to
clean up some language that got
inadvertently left out of a bill last
year
and while edna had it we added at the
request of the commissioner
some
minor
rearrangement of titles and
clarification and update of job duties
and we added
we increase the amount of the
non-lapsing revolving fund
commissioner arlinghaus explained it to
the committee the only detail that i
remember clearly is that this fund used
to be half supplied by agency
and half from the general fund so it
made sense
general fund
however that was stopped it's now
entirely funded from agency funds for
training their people and therefore the
amount should be larger
because there is no general funds in it
and
and of course there's always inflation
and stuff like that to deal with and if
you have questions about the amount of
the fund
i have commissioner arlinghus here to
answer them
oh
thank you representative mcguire
uh anybody have a question other than
the amount
represented almy
other than the amount and i'm delighted
uh that the directors here just
commissioners here just in case
you don't know this what happened when
you reorganized
the divisions what happened to dedicated
funds
this was the only fund that was affected
we didn't no no no i'm sorry i don't
mean about on the money in the fund i
mean the reporting of the dedicated
funds they used to be in
i'm sorry we didn't go into that and i'm
not really aware of the details thank
you
any further questions if not
if the commissioner
come up
hi i'm for the record i'm charlie
arlinghaus
of canterbury i guess we do towns
from the department of administrative
services
the dedicated funds question um
nothing's happened to dedicated funds
all right so we so it's important to
note this nothing's actually being
reorganized the title of one of the
divisions is changing
the division that we used to call
financial data management because they
just did not just the financial side you
know if you think of the erp it's
multiple modules the state computer
system
and so what they do is not really manage
financial data they manage the whole
kit and caboodle and so whole kit and
caboodle didn't sound that official so
it's
so we worked the word enterprise in so
that's actually literally the only
reorder that happened
but i just just want to make sure i
understand so
uh when we want to find dedicated the
dedicated funds reporting from now on it
will be under the division of enterprise
applications management
uh typically in our operation as
accounting services dana calls the
comptroller and uh and matt johnson
who's the new tim hartshorn on her staff
are typically who do all of that work
and i think we we put the dedicated
funds report on that division's
website
accounting services
accounting services accounting services
yes it's really hard to find
are you all set representative yes thank
you uh representative romney
thank you mr chair thank you uh mr
arlinghaus uh just want to make sure no
general funds in this this is
self-feeding from
what feeds it what kind of things so the
so the bureau of education and training
which is part of dop uh division of
personnel um used to be funded 50
general funds and 50 tuition payments
which comes from agencies so it could
easily be general funds uh agencies and
cities and towns
in the last phase the governor's budget
director in the last budget process
said that we could either eliminate it
or make it entirely self-funded through
tuition payments and so it's funded
through tuition payments it's why we
want to retain the tuition payments that
cross the fiscal year line
um
and so the lion's share of it comes from
agency funds and they could be general
funds but when we get them they stop
being general funds and that's the
reason for raising a hundred thousand
yeah so um when it when you're 50
generally funded you know i don't want
to say that nobody cares but at the end
for the year you know you you some of
the money goes away it's just not a big
deal but when when you have to eat what
you kill so to speak um
we need to roll it over
that explains it thank you thank you
any other questions
thank you commissioner thank you for
having me
anybody else have any information they'd
like to share with the committee
dealing with house bill 1288
thank you
then i'm going to close the public
hearing on house
and work session on house bill 1288.
okay before we go on
this is a question the committee members
and the questions of the committee
members
does any
member of the committee have a problem
if we go into executive session
to pass this bill
if you do raise your hand
then we're going to go into executive
session on house bill
representative do you have a motion
second
representative
moves ought to pass on high school 1288
second by representative romney
any other discussion
questions
saying then i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the vote on house bill 1288
[Music]
thank you mr chair
the motion is
about to pass the bill is 1288. we'll
begin the voting with representative
abrami yes
no vote
representative griffin
or hillary or dussette representative
lang yes
the clerk votes yes representative
jeanigan
yes
representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tutor
uh representative aaron
yes representative all me yes
representative ames yes
representative malloy
yes
the honorable representative thomas c
schamberg
yes mr clerk thank you sir
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo yes representative lofman yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative murphy yes chairman major
yes
with the vote being 17 to nothing the
motion about to pass passes
and without objection it will appear on
consent
i see no objection so be on consent
calendar
okay and then we're closer
all right we're going to switch to
just for a short while
to house bill 1598.
we have the commissioner
malcolm here
and let's see the cefo
tina
you know
should just hold it
morning mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
i'm joseph malika
chairman of the new hampshire wicker
commission and with me is our cfo tina
dominic and can you bring the mike
closer to you apparently
is that better yeah
okay
thank you
if you give your names again sure for
the record i'm joseph mallick i'm the
chairman
of the new hampshire liquor commission
and with me is our cfo tina damiers
okay
and again i'll say good morning mr
chairman and members of the committee
good morning
representative romney
uh thank you both for being here um
thank you
thanks for having us
um
we handed out last meeting your analysis
of of where you thought the revenues
would come in
and that was included
the math there included edibles because
this is one big issue we have to we're
addressing hairs edibles going to be in
the spill or not
and then but this morning you handed me
and it's for everybody it's
in the packet the green the green folder
um kind of next to the last document
there's a map united states
um which is a different cut at this
their
their estimates
came in at 50 this is a work such as
only a little more right right this is a
work session so
their estimates originally came in
around 50 million ish on the average
um
the marijuana commission number came in
about the same
about 50 million
we have another document that was handed
out
from another bill
uh 2 237 which was a full
commercialization bill
that
came in at
we gotta add two numbers it was they
that bill called for taxation at the
wholesale level at the at the grower
level and then taxation at the retail
level
so when you add the two together it was
around uh 20 million
to call it 35 million
and that's that and and this all depends
on what tax rate you want to use and
these were based at pretty low tax rates
and i think and this was randy cushing's
bill uh wrapped up
delayed running cushing and
he i think in this bill he purposely
picked low rates um
of taxation so that that's the range
that was that we are so
so we're in the ballpark somewhere in
in the 40 million to 50 million maybe 60
million
but
you know every any way you look at this
there's different cuts at this
it's certainly not 200 million
okay it's not 300 300 million in terms
of the net
and all the numbers that is quoted
included edibles your numbers included
edibles
now
the new piece of information um is this
document and i'm going to look at you
tina and help us out
with this it's in your folders
good morning
i was doing some further research and
found
the institute on taxation and economic
policy
and
in reviewing this
found that the numbers support the 50
million that we were originally looking
at so if you look at the first map where
it talks in new hampshire it's giving
you a projection of what new hampshire
would look like
based on the
washington model and the protection
these numbers were back from 2019 so if
you look at the sheet that we provided
previously in our fiscal note you'll see
that washington
came in
um
i think it's on the second
which page was it on the second page on
the bottom washington um came in at 480
and the projections that we had before
were
right in line so we were just using this
as for further support to show how we
originally did our estimates on a per
capita basis to how the institute was
looking at the taxation per state
and that was with edibles correct
and our bill
does not have edibles but only
edibles associated with medical
a medical card yeah okay
questions from the committee reps and
allow me
thank you on this itap sheet
this revenue could tax israel
is in your state
were these done before they started
getting their data in
um this was from 2019 yeah
so even though they said could they were
basing it on what they'd already seen
yes yes
thank you
okay and you said it was representative
39 taxation rate which is pretty high
actually yes
so so this would be kind of a really
high number
using their model correct that's why the
number's 71 million versus the 50 that
we were looking at which was around the
20 percent okay
mr chair can i
go
continue okay so that that's that's the
revenue there's more discussion we'll
have more discussion on revenues as we
go on here today
um because that's the whole
i mean main the main enchilada in our
discussions is what what's what's the
revenue going to be um
so
just for the since you hear uh
commissioner
uh you envision just just give the
committee a sense of what you envision
in terms of stores and their locations
and their uh they're going to be
storefronts
that kind of thing
sure i thank you
well what we'd like to see first and
foremost i'd like to to reiterate and
reinforce that the liquor commission is
neutral on this bill and
we were asked to do a fiscal note and we
did a fiscal note to the best of our
ability obviously we run an 800 million
dollar business we know a little bit
about retail and profits and enforcement
and i think
quite frankly we're happy that we had
the opportunity to do it
what i would like to see is a separate
branding
a separate uh freestanding store i don't
think that this
you know originally this was
there was some talk of this being in the
liquor stores we never felt that that
was a good idea these should be uh
separately branded in stores that are
separate
we would follow our model because our
model works well we would
place the stores
with like-minded retailers
and retailers of volume
obviously fifty percent of our business
in our
uh retail liquor sales comes from
cross-border we would expect to have the
lowest prices in new england because
there would not be a tax structure tied
to it like there is in many other states
and in massachusetts for instance the
exides tax on cannabis overtook the
excise tax in liquor in year two
so
there's no uh mistaking that
massachusetts is successful
and their
their tax revenue shows it
we would we would run our stores for
lack of a better way to put it we'd run
it much like a jewelry store you'd go
into a store there'd be a small space
probably nothing larger than 3 500 or 4
000 square feet including the back room
everything would be put in cases there
wouldn't be anything out for people to
come in contact with so you're going
into uh you know okay jewelers or any
jewelry store things are in cases the
product is in the cases
the employees would need to
come up to speed as far as education and
sales are concerned of the product
part of our
repertoire that we had asked for would
to be included would be a negociant much
like in the wine business there's wine
negotiates they educate uh they educate
the consumers they educate the people
that work in the stores to the product
how the product is sold the effects of
the product we feel that that would be a
good model for us to follow because
obviously we're successful retailers and
and we do a large amount of volume but
we're not in the cannabis business so
we'd want to be brought up to speed on
that
and we'd like to place the stores
uh
on the borders to
be quite frank about it uh we we want to
that's 10 stores would take a period of
time
uh we were asked to do 10 we thought 10
would be the best way it could be more
stores in the future
but the the model of uh
as we've spoken to this morning the
model stores in place were
in agreement with that and uh
i don't know what else i can i i can add
for you
so representative romney talking about
the stores so in the bill
as
it came to us
is uh opt
out
clause for the uh towns
now
many towns are going to miss that opt
out first off
you know um and talking to the municipal
they think it'd be better if it was an
opt-in but that's
another discussion
um but
i just want to ask you when it comes to
your liquor stores
do you have any of their provisions
where a town has a say whether we place
this liquor store in their town or not
or city
no
all right there's so this will be a
little bit different than that so
so there's no restriction on the liquor
part of the what they of their business
but in this bill we're allowing towns to
say no we don't want a cannabis store or
any any cannabis operation whether it's
growing or manufacturing or retail
so that's just something for the
committee to keep in mind
that there may be some towns that are
just going to
opt out
of it so i just wanted to
well you were here to ask you that
question about i had there was one in
the back of my mind i mean they asked
somebody about that
so you have no problem with the liquor
store
liquor liquor placement
but then
do you think
do you think it'll be harder for you
to place to
get
strip malls or whatever
to agree
to have
store fronts
turned into stores to sell cannabis than
liquor
if we were looking at this five years
ago i'd say yes it probably would have
been but i think in you know in today's
world in today's retail world this is
certainly something that's become much
more acceptable obviously we're the only
state we're kind of an island we're the
only state that doesn't do it
everybody around us does
and uh i know that maine has a different
model uh the towns actually
uh individually charge for licenses of
retail
and some towns are very high and some
towns are much less so i think there
might be
an opportunity for the towns here if
they wanted to do an individual type of
license
and charge the state
there might be
there might be some sort of
incentive for the towns to be able to do
that but i don't think in today's retail
market i think it's much more acceptable
i think the consumers are much more
accepting of it
and my my biggest thing
originally with this and looking at it
is i didn't want to cross lines between
our liquor consumers
and our cannabis consumers because there
are certainly folks that come into our
liquor stores now
that
would be turned off by it and we have a
lot of obviously in the highway we have
a lot of families that come into our
stores we have people that come through
you know they buy they buy their
children a hot chocolate out front and
and they get a sandwich and then they
come into our liquor store as a family
and i'd we wouldn't want obviously to
turn anybody off by doing that so i
think having the stores separate is key
and as far as the towns are concerned i
mean we would abide by whatever the
towns wanted
obviously we're we're not in the
business to be contentious in any way
either with our stores or with with
these potential cannabis stores
and we're at the point now with our
brand and our model where uh we have
more towns than juanas than not so i'm
hoping that in the future that we would
see the same with
this i have one i have one more question
oh let's
i can i can hold my question
you want me to ask it
okay
go ahead yeah
so talking about
cross-border sales
obviously it's illegal to
buy marijuana in new hampshire and take
it back to massachusetts understood
so
i would imagine that would curtail it
wouldn't be a good look
i don't put words in your mouth but it
wouldn't be a good look for new
hampshire to be advertising in in uh
massachusetts
the way you do for liquor because liquor
is legal
you know so
can you just speak to that real quick
as far as the advertising campaign and
what we would do that wouldn't be part
of our campaign and it certainly
wouldn't be something that takes place
as far as an advertising is concerned uh
but you know i drive down the mass pike
as anyone else does and uh i'm you're
inundated with billboards pretty much
throughout new england as to cannabis
being sold in whatever state you're in
obviously other than new hampshire and
if you visit any of the stores in
massachusetts
or maine
much like our stores have a lot of
out-of-state plates those locations have
a lot of out-of-state plates as well so
as far as the law is concerned i'm
certainly sure that we're going to abide
by the letter of the law however
i think there's some personal rights
involved here that we would you know you
don't go out and check license plates at
liquor stores and i think this would be
the same and it would be difficult to do
uh at cannabis stores
i would agree with you on that
it's just going to happen yeah
thank you
representative ames
a couple of questions um
i beg your pardon representative aims
put on your microphone oh sorry i'll
start over
thank you let's see if this works okay
um much better much better
okay i'll start over you're working with
a wholesale market in liquor
that is worldwide
and highly varied in terms of uh
uh offerings of product yeah and
that's what you're used to working with
you're very adept
at finding a good product
that will work in terms of the market
you're trying to market to and selling
that product
and making
a good
profit
we do our best thank you well we
appreciate it
um
now we're talking about cannabis
and as per the discussion a moment ago
uh
essentially your
wholesale market
your product market
is confined to confined to
new hampshire
uh
very very different it's also not as
varied a product
i mean surely there are attempts to
create variety to attract
consumers to establish niches and so
forth but uh
it's it's really
very different from what you're used to
how do you see that affecting
uh your ability to
to become the sort of the premier the
place to go to
for buying cannabis
well i think one of the things that we
looked at and one of the things that we
thought about was
you know obviously
new hampshire
has been forever known as an
agricultural state
we have a lot of family farms
small farms
uh one acre two acre
and some of these facilities that i've
personally visited in maine are not much
more than that and producing a large
amount of cannabis
i believe there's uh
650 growers in the state of maine now
and they cannot keep up with the amount
of cannabis that's being sold
so one of the things that i
when i one of the things that i think
that we're
if if we decide if you decide to get
involved in this business
is this is this could be an agricultural
windfall for the state of new hampshire
this could be an agricultural windfall
for all these small farms and small
family plots that could get licensed and
could sell now could they could have one
crop a year or they could have five
crops a year depending on how much money
they want to put into it but rather than
selling or along with selling some
tomatoes and cucumbers and pumpkins out
front
this could this could turn into
a real windfall that for these folks
that in some respects have suffered over
the years
so i i don't see
it
being
i actually see it being
uh
an enhancement and and something that
could help people in the state and i
think that there would be a lot more
people that are willing to grow
than we might think
okay
i agree i agree agree with that
sentiment
the bill has a limit to cultivator
licenses right now of 15.
does that make sense to you no it does
not
i think that would be a mistake
yeah
okay
all right
thank you
uh
so
sort of on another front the uh
the model that you've built on us
actually not
in this
legislation
is a roughly 10 store
let's call it start
in contrast in massachusetts they've got
more than 350
retail
outlets
in uh maine they've got about 75 i think
vermont's just starting so we don't know
but lots lots of places to go to
all over those states
4 10 is
is very very different it's consistent
with the liquor
approach although i don't know exactly
how many outlets you have
uh but just under 70 and we're opening
three new ones at this point so we just
at 70. yeah okay
at one point we didn't have 80.
so is this going to work
with 10 stores
i think that that 10 stores
representative is was a was a starting
point for us i think that they'll in the
future need to be more stores i think
that uh depending on the model and the
financing model that comes out of this
committee uh we'll we'll be able to look
at that and and make our decisions but i
think 10 stores is
an opportunity for us to get into the
business
and and be competitive and be highly
competitive
and then look at
future offerings as the public demands
it and and and much like in the liquor
business uh you know consumers tell us
where
they want our stores to be for the most
part i mean obviously with like-minded
retailers of market baskets and shaws
and hannafords and
you know i think that the consumers will
will let us know we're going to part of
our model would be to strategically
place them throughout the state
all over the state the original 10 and
then fill in as we as we go along and
depending on the model of financing
obviously the more money that we can
roll back into the business the more
stores we can add and the success would
be greater
just one more follow-up sorry follow-up
uh
so uh
if we start at that level it makes sense
to start small oh this is new
would that affect
our
revenues in other words we
we're gonna start low um as we're gonna
have to finance that startup because you
know we don't
you know it's your stores it's the
state's stores and we're going to have
to pay for it
so we start small
with 10
and build up
that suggests to me that we
if we anticipate a revenue level up here
say 70 million dollars
we're not going to get there for a while
that's correct
i think that that would take a period of
time and you know anyone that knows me
or knows tina knows that we're very
conservative in our numbers i'd rather
uh surprise you with success than
disappoint you with failure
so
that's how we're that's how we're
looking at this and that's how we look
at everything that we do i appreciate
that thank you thank you representative
representative news followed by
representative thank you mr chairman
thank you commissioner thank you both
for being here today uh we are very
anxious to hear more from you today um i
just have a clarifying question
you talked about a monetary incentive
for towns
for is this monetary for retail startup
to the towns or is this uh about revenue
generated in the towns because the
stores would be there can you elaborate
on what you meant by that sure
i think there would be a little bit of
both but i i know that some of the
states have a model of buy town if the
towns choose to allow it there's a
benefit to them because they would give
the retailer the the liquor commission
the state a license to operate in that
town
so there's the incentive for the town to
not opt out
so and in in some towns i've known it to
be as high as 50 000
and in some towns i've known it to be as
low as 2500
depending on the town in the state so
thank you
represent elmi
uh
i'm afraid i don't have the benefit of
having been in the group that was
was figuring out questions uh
but the first one is you'd in the fiscal
note put your expenses in doing this
uh
and
on do you still stand by those same ones
or
would you be revising them and you're
talking about
the startup costs and then the
operating costs
we'd stand by
yeah okay
as i said as we've said representative
we we tend to be conservative in that
approach
uh i think that the numbers that we
looked at per square footage of
developing these stores and developing
this brand
i know that we had asked for some
additional money to advertise
uh if if that's not the uh
if that's not the wish of the committee
then we look at it differently and we
and we move forward accordingly
well i i've got a couple of separate
questions but could i have a follow-up
to that follow-up
i understood that it would be illegal to
advertise
because the feds
might come down on that
are they
but they are advertising it sounds like
in in their the other states yes
so
i mean it's amazing to take a ride out
the mass pike quite frankly when you
when you get beyond when you get beyond
uh worcester and and
and even some spots between boston and
and worcester and framingham but the
billboards are incredible the amount of
money that the state of massachusetts is
spending to advertise cannabis i i don't
know what the actual number is but it's
got to be a staggering number those
billboards are not cheap
thank you and
and
the second
question
is
first you said that
the 10 stores were only going to be on
the borders to out-compete our neighbors
which leaves the entire interior of the
state
unserved when an awful lot of them are
trying to get
access
right now
well i think one of the things we looked
at was
obviously we don't want any community or
any part of the state to go unserved
should you decide to do this
and we would look at that
when i say on the borders i don't mean
necessarily on the border of west
lebanon or
on the border of of you know in salem i
mean where consumers can get to the
stores and they're
associated with other retailers so
do i see some
being in border towns rochester
keene nashua
salem
portsmouth
west lebanon
yeah i do
because
there are two towns right we fish where
the fish are just
said they'll do it
did you have another question yes i did
um
and this one
okay i'll remember that i hope
uh
this other one on
i'm really concerned about
on in my experience what and i
i don't smoke marijuana i can't get
anything out of smoking marijuana and so
it was easy to make that decision a long
time ago
but i do know that the people who do
smoke marijuana
care deeply about the quality of it
it's not
it's not as
simple thing to grow marijuana and keep
it consistent
in quality
and
most i think most of the places that are
growing it are growing it in factory
farms essentially
they're growing it inside under
controlled conditions with controlled
soil and et cetera et cetera and then
they have a product that they
they
more or less guarantee
uh if we go to
doing it on people's back lots
a lot of different people
how are we going to control equality
well i think just like any market
the
the market
tells you what the quality should be and
obviously the quantity of growers should
be but i certainly from a from a
business perspective
don't feel that limiting the amount of
licenses is the right thing to do
because then we're only serving the few
i think that the piece that we had put
in put in there
to have a negociant someone who has the
expertise in the field to go out
to investigate what's being grown how
it's being grown where it's being grown
and bring us the product that they feel
that we should have
that's that was the mindset behind that
wording and that position
we're not experts in this field but
there's many people that are and i think
that this would be a highly sought after
position quite frankly
i don't think i understand what a
negociant is then i thought it was
somebody in the store who was helping
people
pick among different things there but
someone who would have to go out to all
of the little farms that you're talking
about
and at various times during the season
and the harvesting
uh
to
see how they're doing it
would be quite a different proposition
well i i we we called the position in
the negotiate i'm not sure if you
changed the wording of of what that
position actually was but in the wine
world the negotiator goes to the
vineyards
and tries looks at the grapes looks at
the vines the health of the vines the
health of of the product the soil the
terroir
and then
goes and tastes the wine
and makes
uh you know discoverable images of the
wine it's earthy it's green it's
it is what it is this is the type of
person that we would need to have to go
to do the same thing to look at the
flower to look at the plants to see how
it's grown to test it the thc levels etc
i'm not an expert in it and that's why i
think that there's
there's people out there and we we asked
for one as a startup
you you may end up with more than one
and you may end up in a situation where
it's regional but these folks would go
out and work with these folks who are
growers to tell them what first and
foremost what the consumers are looking
for we don't want them growing something
that consumers aren't looking for so
we're going to pattern them to we're
going to this negotiate would pattern
them to say this is what the consumers
are looking for this is what they're
buying in other states this is what we
need you to grow
just with respect
this is an annual plant
it is not
grapevines
no no ma'am
okay
i want to go to some other reps right
now
the order is represent aaron followed by
representative nunes and representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr chair
and thank you so much for coming in and
talking to us today
my question is about um advertising
and
do you foresee that you would use the
same sort of advertising strategy that
you do for
the liquor
for liquor and beer wine
and so far as
when you do your advertising budget for
the liquor outlets
do you do that based on um
a percentage of
your income percentage of sales
how how do you how do you foresee
transitioning that kind of model to
uh selling cannabis
well i think now
that
the ability to advertise is going to be
limited when you start i think it really
depends on what the federal government
chooses to do
i think at at some point there may be a
a change of heart from the federal
government
is in in looking at how cannabis is
sold
and how it's financed and how it's
advertised
and i think that that would be something
that we'd have to look at obviously
we're not going to we're not going to do
anything outside of what we're allowed
to do legally
so we'd have to look at
the revenues and the advertising budget
would be based on the revenues
okay thank you very much you're welcome
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um i i want to make a statement here i
think a negociant is
like a market consultant
someone who's an expertise in in the in
that vertical in that area who who knows
the business that would go out and and
talk with the growers about what their
products are about and then would bring
that information uh back and make
determinations on what type of contracts
would be set with these growers correct
that's correct i wanted to clarify that
just a little bit coming from the
consulting world i understand that
um
also um
you know what i think nope i'm sorry um
miss uh representative aaron just asked
the other question for advertising that
i wanted to ask thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
coming and informing us
i noticed in the original
uh
fiscal note that you didn't want a
fourth division
for the cannabis enforcement and
licensing and i'm wondering if the
personnel cost that you might take on at
a higher level are included in the
estimate
of the personnel
and if the negotiate which sounds like
it might be a expensive position
is also in that
i think that the cost of of
of doing business in the original uh
dollars that we looked for there
obviously is going to be some loading
costs some load-in costs when you do
this
and we would ask the committee and we'd
ask
to to look at
obviously folks have to be
made whole shall we say
when they when they open a new division
it's going to be a load on our finance
division in enforcement division and
marketing and so i think there's going
to be a period of time
that part of those funds would be used
to compensate those employees for
writing rules for writing job
descriptions for doing interviews as
well as you know creating office space
etc etc so
to have a separate division we didn't
feel was necessary because all ever we
do everything
already
within the confines of our business that
this business does our model
was
looking at if the federal government
ever had an issue
with cannabis we'd have everybody who
worked on cannabis completely separate
from anybody who worked on liquor so the
dollars could be accounted for
separately the job duties could be
accounted for separately
the only time that i think you'll see
any crossover is in the beginning where
we're where we're building this in and
after that this will just be the
division the lines that we've drawn in
the division will take care of
themselves and they'll be separate unto
themselves
thank you may i have one more question
follow-up um in northampton mass
where my favorite knitting store is one
street over is a dispensary
and they always have or had i haven't
been down for two years because of covid
they always had police in the parking
lot
is that going to be something we'll need
as well i think
i think when massachusetts first opened
the recreational there was a huge demand
and and
i think some of that has waned away as
more stores have opened i think in the
beginning that's we certainly have an
enforcement division and they're
certainly in tune with uh crowd control
and in tune with you know keeping we do
it in our stores at the holiday seasons
so it's it's it's the same but different
we're in the same the same retail
environment and uh we we would expect
that to happen in the beginning and we
have accounted for that as well thank
you very much thank you thank you
representative representative murphy
followed by representative hatch
thank you mr chairman thank you both for
coming in
um i was just curious about the comment
you made about
sound like the mom and pop you know
shops the local farms that would be a
boon if they could grow some of this
product for you
and i was initially thinking of this is
somewhat of a vertically oriented model
whereby you had greenhouses and then you
went to produce and then you went to the
retail shops
does so are you looking at this as a
hybrid model in a sense where you can
have
local growers come in and then you have
your own
greenhouses that you would develop your
own and does that change any way you
model at all
and have no interest in that the growing
end of the business okay that's
something that i think that the that the
free market should should share in and
and obviously profit from as well as the
state and from from an i just
i've always thought originally from an
agricultural standpoint we're a natural
for this we have
we have the farms we have the space
people there's many many thousands of
folks out there that are great farmers
they they know how to grow and this is
this is
right in line with what would serve them
best and put some
profits in their pockets as well as the
towns
great thank you thank you
representative
good morning and thank you for taking my
questions and um i'm i'm thinking along
i'm here primarily for budgetary
concerns and expenditures that are
planned or are requested and one area
that we're approaching on now is
enforcement and that's one thing i was
curious about you have a very capable
group of enforcement officers now you do
and
in
the need for expansion and if i'm
approaching something that's already
been discussed completely let me know
but um
i would be interested in and i would
think there would have to be an
expansion of enforcement
for marijuana or not this is something i
don't
really know but i would like to see what
the plans are how it's being implemented
and
how their role in enforcement is going
to be expanded in terms of um say
unauthorized use or things such as that
or will local
municipalities with their officers be
involved in and how is that interlinked
i just it'd be good to understand that
and the cost of that is is my concern
well i think in our fiscal note
originally we put in additional officers
we put in additional enforcement
personnel
and i would as far as our roles with the
town i would i would allow the chief to
make those decisions on how he would uh
administer whatever rules are written
and working with the towns and
municipalities but we did ask for
uh additional enforcement personnel
in in our original uh
fiscal note
is that um
annotated i haven't seen that note yet
but is that annotated clearly that cost
in the fiscal note or is it
part of the sum or part of the whole i
think it's part of the it's summarized
as the personnel cost but we do have the
breakdown of the positions that we were
expecting to include so we could always
provide that breaking yeah i would like
that
if you could thank you thank you
representative lyon
chair mr jeremy heavier indulgence i
have like a series of i'm trying to get
to the math of numbers so we have a real
idea of what we're doing and it may
involve a little bit back and forth so
if i have a little leeway to have a
dialogue rather than just simple
questions i appreciate it
so thank you commissioner thank you for
taking that question i know we had a
conversation earlier out in the hallway
and i wanted to kind of summarize some
of that conversation is that i think it
was clear in
that this is going to be a rolling
startup
that um
that obviously we're not going to have
10 stores on day one when we snap a
finger in the law the bill becomes law
um and i think we we talked about the
idea of having three to four stores per
year as a roll-up and then ultimately
using the revenue generator from that to
be able to fund the startup of the rest
of the stores so that we don't have to
have as much startup costs the full 14
million
um
so if i do my math right and i'm using
your your cannabis perspective spill
here is that
we know and i think representative
abrami
said about 40 roughly of the revenue
comes from edibles and edibles aren't in
this conversation so any of these
numbers that we're looking at when we
talk about
uh per capita costs or revenues are
going to be 60 of what the projection is
roughly and to use this as a starting
point so as we're using if we if we end
up with a
50 million dollar revenue net revenue
startup start point obviously we we
subtract out our
because we're not selling edibles we're
down to 30 million dollars in revenue if
all 10 stores were open we were
estimating and then we know that in the
first year we're only going to have
about a third of the stores open so then
we got to subtract out make that
one-third of that 30 million so we're
really looking about 10 million to 10.5
million dollars first year revenue
assuming three stores open for a full
calendar year would that be roughly
a correct
uh expectation or rough number
yes i would agree with that okay so
looking at 10.5 million dollar first
year expansion and then every year as
you open three or four more stores in
theory that number doubles it goes from
10.5 to 20 21 and in the third year
comes up to the full whatever the number
is uh 33 and change that 30 million
dollars would that be kind of what we're
looking at a three year to get the full
projections in that third year we'll
start seeing the full revenue of 10
stores
that's an accurate timeline i would
think and to be clear and i think i'm
right in the committee there's actually
no limitation on the number of stores in
this bill the only reason we talked
about 10 stores was we needed a gauge
for startup costs and so the 14 million
dollars we were talking about was okay
assuming we did 10 stores this is what
the cost would be but there is actually
no limitation if i'm correct in the bill
for the number of stores you can use
your ongoing operating revenues to be
able to generate and open more stores
past 10 if you feel there's a need is
that correct
yes so there's a limitation of
cultivators
only on the grower side that's the only
limitation i've already taken a note to
amend my amendment to
get rid of that so
um
so um
i'm sorry go back to numbers uh
so that we've taken care of the revenue
side we're estimating the full year of
of the first one third of the stores up
it's 10.5 million dollars in revenue now
to switch over to the cost side so i'm
looking at
this fiscal note here that had all of
the block graphs talking about startup
construction everything else and again
if i do my math the rough personnel cost
for all ten stores was five million
dollars if all stores were running the
personnel cost is five million dollars
but we're actually looking at a revenue
expectation of one point i mean a
revenue cost because again if we ramp up
the personnel along with the
the stores it's about 1.65 million per
year and that number will grow until you
get to the third year and have all 10
stores open and we'll be at a full
um five million dollar personnel roughly
i'm not trying to yeah well the only
thing i would say about that is the
structure of the personnel was to start
up the office like the headquarters to
have the enforcement people the finance
people the hr
and then adding in store personnel so
there might be more of an upfront cost
in the personnel with the breakdown that
we have of the positions that we were
looking for
okay so i guess i'm just trying to get
to what the what out of the revenue what
are we going to actually spend in that
first year assuming you know the first
full operational year so i i
on a per store basis it looks like we're
looking at an annual cost of around
350 000 per store is that right i think
that was where i found the number was
350 000 per store is the operational
expense for a store
and then we have the personnel cost of
1.6 million on top of that and that's
going to grow as both the operational
costs and the and the personnel costs
will grow
you know linearly
in theory right we'll use that for
modeling so again we're looking at in
the first year if you would open three
stores it's a roughly 1.3 million
dollars in operational expenses for the
stores and then roughly 1.6 million
dollars
we'll call it 2 million because i know
the personnel aren't linear so you got
to have some people in place like hr
before you hire store staff so i will
say it it's two million dollars in the
first year so we're looking at 1.6
million dollars in operating expenses
for the first year to get the first
store up or first sets of stores up
roughly so we have numbers
great
last thing i just want to comment on it
was something i just made note we talk
about law enforcement and enforcement
and it's true that um all of your liquor
inspectors are certified full-time
police officers in new hampshire police
standard training they've already had
the drug training and what's legal
what's not legal and and those kind of
things already so it's just a matter of
hiring another full-time police officer
and maybe giving some specialized
training relative to this specific law
but uh because it'll be new um but other
than that they're already full-time
police officers with full-time arrests
and investigation and
detention capabilities correct they're a
fully well-rounded police department yes
um i think i got the math out of the way
i think that took care of most of the
items we we know generally what the idea
is now on revenue you know generally
about the ideas on costs and
and i can talk to the amendment and some
of the things i did to address that and
what i talked to finance and got
well i have a favor still pending with
the chairman i don't have i didn't have
a favor with with the chairman of
finance but i did get some commitments
from her that we can talk about
all right that was going to be my
question mr chair
okay
uh representative ronnie yeah
can we spend a few minutes on that and
break the number to everybody we have
two fiscal people here in terms of what
the chair of finance is willing to
absorb
that
for the next fiscal year correct this
next fiscal year
allocation of 4.6 million is that
correct well the gross appropriation
will be five million dollars for this
bill um because we also have the hundred
and fifty thousand dollars that goes to
something else and so
the chair the the chair of finance told
uh the
christie's office what the legislative
budget administrators administration
office that to earmark five million
dollars for this bill
okay so that's the question and with
that in mind
can they react to about how many stores
can we open the first year with five
million i know there's a lot more up
front on the overhead positions internal
to the operation
and then
so that's the kind of number we're
working with so i think it's important
that you know that
um
for that first
just for next fiscal year is that
correct five million for next fiscal
year
and then the anticipation is that after
the first store is open that then it'll
be self-funding if i may mr chair
respond so so again i i
the way the bill was reached the way i
restructured the bill was
initially we had to pay back as the
first item
out of revenue and i inverted that and i
changed the operating expense to the
first item so that they can add their
new stores in as part of their growth
process as part of their operational
expense before we start doing it and the
secondary item i put was the re um
payment of the funds so it gives them a
revenue stream to be able to again
invest back into themselves to open the
next door and open the next door and
open the next store um to get to where
we're finally you know making decent
money to everybody else gets money um
so uh before we go any further
so the question is on the five million
dollars that
gets appropriated can you bring up three
stores the first year
we feel that we can mr chairman okay
thank you
so yeah again so representative obama
yes the idea is to have them reinvent be
able to reinvest some of the funds they
get um before
we start doing another disbursement so
we can get to a full model with
a decent number of stores that generates
enough revenue for everything we want
okay i want to remind the committee
is that we're going to continue the work
session
uh
if we can get through the other bills
this morning
if not we'll continue it in the
afternoon and then we'll also continue
it again on monday
and then
wednesday next week
we have to exec it out
okay
so any further questions of the
commission
yes
thank you mr chair
um
earlier you mentioned how new hampshire
is agricultural and its nature and you
use an example of maine having
650 growers and 75 stores
that's a
8.6 grower to store ratio given a sense
of supply chain
but this new hampshire proposal is
growers for maybe 10 stores maybe more
and more stores would only drive that
ratio from 1.5 cultivators to
storefronts if you want to use that
example we're going to have a supply
chain problem
as far as 8.6 growers to stores in maine
1.5
growers to store fronts in new hampshire
i i think if we limit it to 15
that will as i've as i've said i feel
that that would be an issue one
follow-up
and that 15 limitation
is a real problem with us
and and to further elaborate on the 15
if it if it stays at 15
wouldn't that give great preference to
the largest possible cultivators and
growers and leave out smaller farms i
think it would certainly show
favoritism that's all thank you bye
congratulations
representative
i'm sorry i think
we have to discuss this later
but
small farms
that are not growing indoors can only do
one to two crops
a year at the most
on
small farms
are going to be producing product that
is very different
to the other which is a problem
representing all me
i've been working in i worked in
agriculture for 25 years yeah represent
almi uh
i want to limit this
the commissioner i know and then once
with two of that then we want to go to
the other bills i i did and we'll come
back
okay
now i forgot any other questions i had
before
spellsbury
thank you mr chairman representative
lofman anticipated a good portion of my
question so
it's not typical that states engage in
entrepreneurial business activity like
this fortunately we have
a successful model with the liquor
commission to look at
but
inevitably
an entrepreneurial enterprise has to
work in supply demand conditions where
competition is generally considered an
advantage in terms of
superior service superior product
best pricing etc etc so we don't need to
go
into the economics but
wouldn't
the answer to the 15
producer
issue which i think we all agree is too
constrained
be not to lift it to a higher number but
to rather have no numerical limit on the
number of growers but rather instead
rely on your licensing criteria to
determine who qualifies and let that be
unlimited
i feel that that would be a prudent
business move
thank you very much you're welcome
representative ames
uh
two questions first is uh
about your timeline you're ramping up
the three stores and the first year
that discussion
um
don't you need to have regulations in
place before you
go forward
and how long will that take
i think that you know obviously rules
need to be written and and people need
to be hired within the organization
before we can branch out to the stores
uh i you know rules would take some time
i think that there was an october date
in
uh
the original one of the original drafts
that we feel would be too constraining
and uh
as far as opening the stores i mean
you've seen what we've done with the
liquor and wine outlets and how many
we've opened over a period of time we've
opened as many as seven in one year this
past year we've opened four next year
we'll open four so to open three stores
with the type of
retail footprint that we're talking
about
we feel would be much easier than
opening
a 12 to 25 000 square foot store i mean
these stores are will be small they'll
be uh
technically advanced
because everything has to be taken out
of climatically controlled safes and put
into climately controlled cases and
everything obviously has to be
under uh cameras we'll have smart safes
like we do in our stores now we'll have
armored car pickup like we do in our
stores now so from a technological
standpoint the stores will be compact
but very advanced i feel that we can do
i feel that we can safely do three in
the first year and we may in fact you
know we may in fact be able to do more
depending on
how much groundwork we can get done and
the availability of the products that we
need just like anything else
uh you know
build out takes time we're finding that
steel and and
you know lumber and cases and shelving
are all taking an exponential amount of
time at this point so
okay thank you for that i just have one
follow-up a separate question
it's about revenues and the projection
of revenues and uh
it's not really the ramp up but
but trying to figure out what revenues
will come from this enterprise
um
and uh
i'd like to i'd like to
if you could reach back to give
uh two parts to that estimate one is uh
what what is the number that you're
projecting now a little unclear on that
and then the second thing is uh what
about edibles because we've heard a lot
about how edibles are
a very important part of the uh
of the market and uh the consumers are
that's what many consumers want um and
yet in this bill
as it's written uh edibles are not going
to be on your shelves
so um
i haven't heard anything about how
the absence of edibles affects your
projections
well i think that in in looking at what
edibles do across the country i think
you're looking at somewhere between
35 to 45 of the business in
uh
in a retail location so i think that you
could safely
subtract that number from
projections
uh should should edibles
not be allowed to be in these particular
locations
and the the larger number that
you're working with the
the 35 would come off of what
of the 50 million
of the 50 million 50.
thank you
there's one part the first question was
how long do you
would it take to get the
regulations and
i i don't want to to take a hard and
fast stand on that mr chairman i think
that it would certainly take some time
and we'd have to we'd have to look at
we'd have to look at what was being
asked of the commission from a financial
standpoint uh what we were being asked
to work with i would certainly think
that would wouldn't be
more than i i think it would be
at least six months perhaps a little bit
more
okay i'm six to eight months
representative brownie yeah thank you
yeah the subcommittee that was one of
the issues we talked about
and we all concluded that what was in
the bill was too tight of a time frame
it is so type of
it so the minimum was at least
what did you just say i'm sorry six i
think it would take six months at least
six six
six to nine months
to do to finish the rules yeah
to do the rules
i mean that's getting their part getting
there
then doesn't have to get it to jail car
after that so
when you add that in it's you know
because this is all new i mean they're
starting from scratch here with these
rules i mean this isn't adding rules to
existing agency thank you
robzona tucker
yes i don't remember which of the three
lengthy days we discussed so many
subjects at session
but there was mention made of
the
uh
wages paid to by the liquor commission
at the stores
on the floor at some time and i don't
remember in relation to what
but would you anticipate
the same wage scales
at the cannabis stores as you do uh at
the liquor stores and could you give us
an idea of what those
uh the average
person working at a liquor store makes
because we would end up being employers
right so you are employers and therefore
when they bring it up at a session it's
talking about what we
are endorsing as wage scales
well i can i can tell you that the the
wages at the liquor for the starting
wages at the liquor commission
are uh
around 13 an hour for a clerk
for a labor
and it goes up from there obviously we
follow the same
scale that the state uses our our folks
are paid
at the same scale
now in a cannabis location i feel that
there would be
a great amount of education that these
folks would need to undertake
prior to them working as a retail person
in this store
from a labor standpoint actually meaning
you're not picking up 47 pound average
cases of spirits you're you're from so
from
a strenuous labor standpoint it would be
the labor piece of it would be less
intense but i also feel that there's an
educational piece
that needs to be brought in
and there's certainly
a certain maturity level that we would
expect these employees to have
and i don't feel that following the
state guidelines
is going to attract the type of
employees that we would need
so where we would need to be at this
point i'm unsure because i've done less
homework on that
based on
what private industry is paying but i
can assure you that it would probably be
somewhere
at least
one-third to
50 percent
more than what we're paying our retail
people in the stores now i would project
that we would have to be somewhere in
the 18 to 25 dollar an hour range so
that does make a difference on the
revenues i mean
that
well i think what it does it certainly
does
but i also think that
you know
rent is a function of volume
so
if we run the stores properly which
i can assure you we will
and we have the pricing
that's competitive with the new england
states i feel that uh
our projections are conservative and
i've always we've always taken that
approach in everything we do
and so
would you anticipate
excuse me
thank you
i apologize
uh would you expect the same benefit
packages to be
at
the liquor stores as well as the
cannabis stores
i think that we would follow the state
guidelines as far as full-time benefits
are concerned
and i believe that if we i'm not sure
that we put
any part-time people in the stores and
our projections and if we did it was a
de minimis amount i feel that this is
folks that uh
that would be interested in this type of
thing are there professionals in nature
they they they have the knowledge of the
product uh you know they're involved
with the product already
somewhere and those are the type of
people that we would need to hire
thank you
mr uh commissioner just a quick question
going back to the rules conversation if
i was to amend we did amend the rules
because we recognize in the subcommittee
and the amendment i have but we use
december of 22 but if i was to change
that so it wasn't a hard date and just
said
you have to have it eight months after
rules must be established eight months
after passage would that be reasonable i
think that would certainly be fair
representative thank you
and this may be a question of the chair
mr chairman um
as far as a question would be concerned
about regulation is regulation part of
policy or is regulation part of this
committee
then i'll cut my question thank you
mr chair
chamber
uh thank you mr chair uh this may be a
question for the chair also
uh
uh we have a fiscal note
is there gonna be a representative from
the dra here
about these appropriation numbers
will they be here this afternoon or
tomorrow or monday
they don't get involved with liquor or
will they get involved with us well i
have a follow-up question here then
uh in determining the numbers
since we're talking about numbers
and i see the agencies they contacted
were from administrative services
corrections health and human services
justice revenue safety judicial judicial
council municipal association and the
association of counties
and the gentleman
speaks about agriculture why was the
department of agricultural markets and
foods not contacted about
the cost to them
representative chad's gonna allow me to
answer that so can you look what number
what's the number on the bill you're
looking at on that sheet because there's
one from a prior bill that was rent uh
uh the late randy cushing's bill
and that was that was the very extensive
the numbers that you
yeah those numbers are from the last
major
uh bill we wanted to try to compare
those numbers to
[Music]
this bill so that fiscal note you're
looking at and that's why you see
revenue there
department of revenue actually did the
revenue estimates because it was taxing
then it was tax that was a tax bill this
is not a tax bill this is a net revenue
bill
so so on the top of the breastfeed's
gonna what's the num what's the build
number
minon oh there it is
hb237 right exactly so that's a bill
from last year
that was a full
full
legalization and commercialization bill
traditional model bill that's why that's
what you see there so that
although even with that the revenues i
mentioned that earlier it was
the department of revenue did do those
revenue estimates because it was taxing
they taxed at the agriculture level
and then they taxed at the retail level
and i think it at the upper end it was
like 40 million is what they had come up
with
thank you is that answer your question
okay thank you
representative murphy
thank you mr chairman uh thank you again
i'm just asking since edibles are
currently not in the bill right now what
is the product line that we are talking
about is it
just flowers is it you know topicals
cartridges i mean or is it just flowers
right now
i think it would be anything that was
available for retail sale other than the
edibles which would be flour it would be
topicals it would be uh
concentrate concentrates okay it would
be
it would be vape it would be accessories
okay so it's everything else except for
edibles right now
great thank you
any further questions
representative ames followed by
represent elneny
sorry
we've talked about rules um and
but we haven't talked about how the
rules have to address
cultivators
you're going to be the regulatory
authority
for this whole
whole thing
um and uh
so um cultivators will be part of it and
i have a
a
particular
question about
the product that cultivators will be
growing and then
presumably moving on to
manufacturers
and then moving on to your stores
and that is tracking these
the product from the beginning
to
when it's sold
and in prior bills we've had a tracking
system built into the legislation which
involves unique identifiers
there's nothing about that in this bill
which we've raised as a concern when
we're
meeting as a subcommittee um i wonder if
you thought at all about this the
context of course is there's a black
market
and it's considerable and price has
something to do with
with uh diminishing that i would assume
competition but also
the ease at which or the lack of ease
people playing in the black market can
function
and
i should think identifying the ability
to identify product
uh would relate to that so that's the
context for my question
well i again i go back i go back to uh
the rule making and i go back to the
negotiate because in my mind that person
has the level of expertise to guide the
commission
not only in the rule making but in the
process of cultivation
harvesting and transportation
go ahead and represent
when i checked the liquor liquor when i
chaired the marijuana commission
that was one of our recommendations to
have a tracking system
it did the bill came over to us without
that in it and i didn't bring that one
up really early on because
was that really part of our job here
but it sounds like you'll be addressing
that
if this bill passes
as a need to um other states have that
where they track it
every step of the way in the supply
chain i guess you want to call it the
supply chain of of uh
of the product
okay much like we do with liquor now
right and you know we affidavi so you
don't you don't need something specific
in the bill you you'll be addressing
that as part of your rules it will be
addressed in the rules okay thank you
representative ames are you all through
i am thank you representative
thank you uh
two questions again unfortunately um
oh no they're they're actually together
on what
is enforcement going to be doing
with marijuana that they are not already
doing now just to make sure it isn't
bleeding into the entire law enforcement
on
cannabis
does
do you oh i guess the other one's a
subpart of it
do what are they going to be enforcing
only what's going on in the stores
are they going to be trying to enforce
uh
the the um
product
growing
on
in the on the farms
uh
to see if they're bringing in product
from somewhere else
uh
and your question
this is my question one of one of my two
questions one of them is is that how how
much enforcement do they actually have
to do under this bill
does it only have to be what's going on
in the stores and the supply chain
they would be concerned with
the product in in our stores the supply
chain from from the grower to the stores
and work with as they do now
other local law enforcement agencies and
the state police on anything outside of
that scope if something happens in a
particular town if if they if they see
something going on that
they feel is
is worthy of bringing to a level then
that's that's what they do now we work
hand in hand with the municipalities and
state police now and we would take that
the same way
the commissioner has to leave to go to
fiscal yes and we thank you for
coming here and answering
addressing our questions thank you very
much
okay mr chairman members of the
committee work we appreciate it
work session on house bill
this closed mr
just i think the
enforcement
um representative albany was going there
there's some a myriad of questions that
need to be cleared up for enforced
enforcement i
i mean they don't automatically happen
in rulemaking there's a there's a i see
a gap between what's been explained and
what is needed to know that's all enough
there's a future time where enforcement
can come and iterate on those things
that would be wonderful thank you okay
thank you representative hatch yeah and
we do we do have him here but
you're willing to come back at any one
next week
yeah that may work too well i i actually
i just i think it's better in the open
forum i'm willing to get together
anytime but just just so everybody has a
clear
understanding of the process and what's
going to be done going forward and i
think it's kind of important mr chair it
doesn't have to happen now can happen
anytime
thank you
since we have the enforcement here
we'll take 10 minutes
and i open reopen the work session on
house bill
1598.
thank you mr chair
and if you could identify yourself and
answer the questions
thank you
for the record my name is mark
armagenian i'm the chief and director of
the liquor commission's division of
enforcement licensing
my name is danielle elston i'm the
deputy director of the liquor
commission's division of enforcement and
licensing
representative hatch thank you mr chair
i think it would be worthy maybe for
everybody
and thank you for staying and taking the
questions it's just explain uh what
enforcement will do
the skyview picture of what you'll be
doing in terms of enforcing cannabis
from start to finish i i
just in my mind and i'm glad you
referenced that you'll
be working very closely with other law
enforcement agencies who are overseeing
this now
and and that dynamic won't change that
much or will it and and if you could
just explain
the extent of your environment and
enforcement for cannabis
going forward is that
clear enough i mean
it is it is thank you for your question
representative
um
first and foremost um i think we've
testified several times that our
uh
our partnerships with our municipal
partners and state partners is
overwhelmingly great
um we are in and thank you for bringing
that up earlier and i know i've
testified in front of you guys
a handful of times on on this issue who
we are and what we do
um right now we are uh regulating the
industry of alcohol and tobacco
which kind of gets forgotten uh the
tobacco side of it this is very similar
to that infrastruc infrastructure
um we as uh representative almi brought
up uh we would be looking at this and
and the chairman said so eloquently
we're looking at this from a level of
the tier system
um there are many states that do it that
way regulate that way from
what we would look at manufacturing on
the
uh alcohol side of the house we're
looking at cultivation
on the cannabis side of the house and we
would be regulating from that level all
the way through with our not only our
investigators that have been earmarked
to do this
these duties but also with our uh
civilian auditors
who will be trained in in this specific
uh realm
um when it comes to
uh our infrastructure
as the chairman brought it up i i
foresee this and we've had uh
conversations about this breaking down
further into a bureau system uh such as
what i came from over at state police
where
we would be looking at
the bureau of cannabis control
in that cannabis control as long as the
model right now that we're looking at
is a state model and not a privatized
model
we could do that with approximately
the way we look at it now about uh for
investigators
with a leadership structure to that
um
auditors we're looking at three auditors
and and we also have a licensing
component of that too because we'd have
to add staff to the front end of the
house
for a lack of a better term
um
and and
we do foresee
that
um
a a possibility we don't know this is an
unknown but a possibility of a black
market
we deal with that now on the alcohol and
tobacco side of the house
we have a special investigative unit
that deals with
fraud rings
and
theft rings throughout the state
uh bootlegging tobacco into this state
uh there is a bootlegging we don't see
it because
as as most of you know um i'm not from
the marketing side of the house but we
sell alcohol pretty darn cheap
so we don't have the bootlegging problem
that we do
that we see with tobacco
and we have an infrastructure that
is set up in model form right now
to
deter against that with
our the assistance of our our local and
state partners
did i answer your question uh
representative hatch
yes thank you i just wanted to overview
and then
for example if there is
enforcement taking place
and somebody is
illegally selling or utilizing cannabis
in whatever manner
how far the agency takes it to
adjudication or for the most part you
would be would you be turning that over
to other
law enforcement entities to carry it
through adjudicating because that can
take a lot of time ergo costs absolutely
that's a very good question thank you
for it um as you as you know and and
we've had conversations there are
certain cases that we will take to
fruition
um and
and from its inception on through
um the reason for that is the continuity
of the case consistency with the case
continuity of evidence
uh but i foresee and i know a lot of you
have heard me say this
um i foresee this um uh
venture if you will
to be handled the same way as everything
else in the division that's starting
accountability with our education
platform we believe education is going
to be a big part of this
and it's going to be a big part of
assisting
us assist our new prospective licensees
and being in compliance
we believe that um
we have proven
i i should correct myself we have proven
that that education platform
has been very very
adequate in
having industry actually
in a
in a different sense
supporting our endeavors
the people we re regulate like us
um that's different throughout the
country um because sometimes it's the
iron fist coming down and not telling
people
how
how what did i do wrong how did i do it
wrong
and i'm sure you're going to come in
next month and
tell me i'm doing it wrong again and
you've never told me what i did wrong so
we believe from an auditing view all the
way through to the regulatory portion of
it and and
enforcement
um begins with that education piece
and i know you've heard me talk about
that quite often
representative hatch anything else
anybody else if if i could uh
deputy uh chief uh elston had a little
bit more to add to that if i could give
her a couple seconds if that's why
another you know building out on that
educational platform is also going to be
the youth access to to the product where
the primary law enforcement agency and
the youth access to tobacco
also you know we regulate the industry
in terms of youth access with alcohol so
a large component of that enforcement
umbrella
involves um preventing the youth access
to cannabis
representative tucker followed by
representative alani
yes i was just
thinking about the differences between
liquor and cannabis
so
when you buy liquor
if you're buying it by the drink or
whether you're buying it by the bottle
at a liquor store
the rules of where you can use
and consume that product are very clear
but with cannabis
how is it going to work where will one
know where one can consume the cannabis
will there be
smoking in restaurants
will there be outdoor patios can you go
to a
baseball stadium and use it
public spaces
how are we going to manage this aspect
of
giving the state seal so to speak
that it's all right
to buy and use cannabis how will that
translate
into the day-to-day operations of the
state and where people can use that
cannabis and that seems to fall
to some extent under enforcement how
would more people
know how they can
help people know where they can consume
the product
well first of all thank you for your
question representative i think first of
all
enforcement does just that and i've been
successful in this career for 35 years
living by that and and that that adage
and that is that we enforce the laws
that you all create here
um
we are going to be diligent with our
rule making on this we feel that the
making can
create bookmarkers if you will
we will
also assist all of you in
seeing what the industry standards are
throughout the country
and and coming up with the best if that
is what you all choose and the other
uh the other committees uh throughout
this building that are involved in this
choose to do
um we will help you um make sure that
the people that have chosen
to consume
this product are the ones that actually
um are the ones that are ingesting it um
just like tobacco i mean we always think
liquor but we regulate tobacco in this
state also and it's very similar to
tobacco and nicotine
thank you
a comment from representative romney yes
so in the bill they do have provisions
for
no smoking outdoors any public place
is in the build so that's that's taken
care of
and i can't recall if if
sometimes you get my things mixed up
whether it's in this bill or another
about apartment buildings
not not being able to smoke in apartment
buildings because it goes from one
apartment to the other i'm not quite
sure if it's in this bill or not but
definitely no outside public place can
you smoke or or even use edibles no nor
in any moving vehicle
nor anything and then moving vehicles
moving the vehicle right
apart
yeah i'm not talking about tobacco we're
talking about marijuana and i've seen
i've seen some
states that have banned it from
apartment buildings and i can't recall
if it's in this bill or not that's all
thank you okay representative army
thank you i think i counted up at least
eight new staff for enforcement
about how much
is that like and some of them are high
level the auditors
about how much is that
in the personnel costs
um i would only be
it probably would be
irresponsible for me to give you a
figure right now representative and
thank you for your question
just because i don't have that flow
chart with me and i don't have the exact
numbers on benefit costs
and i think tina tina was the perfect
person to have for that question
um i could i could ballpark it but it
would be irresponsible for me to do that
at this point but it's about eight staff
um
i'm looking at approximately eight staff
correct with leadership involved thank
you
and oversight ask a question
about edibles if we do not do edibles
there will be a black market in edibles
on are you going to be responsible for
that or will that be someone else
um
thank you thank you representative um
right now to be quite
frank about this there are edibles out
there right now oh yeah um we know that
cbd is in our combination stores right
now it's a problem that we've been
talking with the
dea on
um
and
of course cbd topical is legal because
of the federal farm bill
uh but the
adulterated products aren't um we we
would we would do as we do right now
with those products and our combinations
that show up
we handle those issues
that is something that traditional law
enforcement hasn't wanted to touch
and and i can't actually point at one
jurisdiction or another but
with all the other
issues that are going on in the
traditional law enforcement world it's
something that we would actually be
regulating also
thank you that helps representative
romney that's defining a term
uh combination stores what are those oh
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
grocery stores convenience stores i'm
sorry
thank you
any further questions of the enforcement
office branch
saying none thank you okay thank you
i'm closing the work session
on house bill 1590 eight right now right
just up
we're going to pick up in the afternoon
because a lot of them are here for them
oh yeah
and
this afternoon we'll we'll pick up the
work session on this bill
but right now i want to go to
house bill
1537 work session
and that's relative definition of a
cigar bar
does the committee
have
questions relative to this bill
on
12 37
because if there's no questions and if
you're satisfied i'd like to um
execute this bill
can we just pause for a minute to get
the papers out
just trying to find the papers okay
um
can i ask a question
yes
can someone just go over the concerns we
did have when at the hearing because i
don't remember either i didn't bring my
papers
representative bernstein
he's going to pop his
because when you do look at the bill
it changes
it adds to cigars it adds
cigarettes
loose tobacco
and it eliminates
from the definition
as well as revenue generated from other
tobacco sales in stores including
cigarettes and loose tobacco sales
can i so can i get it
yeah so
raid
revenue from keno
mail order and internet sales
should not be used to determine whether
an establishment satisfies the
definition of a cigar bar
so mr chair
okay representative ames do you have
your
paperwork i've got my favorite word okay
representative so here's my his what i
see here
it sounds this bill it seems like this
bill was filed for one store
um
and we had we had uh testimony from the
cigar association of new hampshire
which represented five owners in 12
retail locations
and they didn't see a need for this bill
the bill is really
there to
help them help this one store hit the 60
percent
mark
in terms of tobacco uh
cigars or tobacco products being sold
um
i i don't think we need i don't
at this moment i'm an itl
on this because i i don't think we
should change our current statute to and
and that one story i don't think
testified if i recall
uh clutier it's his bill i think
uh they both talked about
this one store that
feels without this they can't hit that
60 percent so
so that's my understanding
representative
i think that's very well put except that
codier i think was representing the
store owner
other than that i agree entirely
representing
um thank you mr chairman my sense was
that the bill is originally drafted had
a serious problem
a because it was changing the formula by
lowering the percentage threshold and
and b because it was temporary and
therefore was going to
whip back in a couple of years
but
my sense is from the perspective of this
committee the commerce um committee
solved that problem if they're okay with
it and the house is okay with it i'm not
sure what the ways and means issue is
you and then representative
yes i just wanted to say that i um
echo what uh representative abram and he
said
the cigar association
had no issues with it at all and um and
i think it might have been
representative stapleton that mentioned
that um
with the pandemic people weren't
frequenting um cigar bars and as much
but i mean we're kind of
nearing the end of of that where you
know mass mandates are being lifted
people are starting to go out a lot more
i think this is a temporary problem
that's um
in one specific instance that is most
likely going to go away anyhow so i
think i'm i would also
be itl on this
representative line followed by
represents
so i i guess i agree with representative
spillsbury that
i'm not sure what
what we're doing here
commerce fix the problems with the
temporary nature and those kind of
things we're down just left to whether
or not we agree that the percentage
should include loose cigarettes and
loose tobacco versus just straight cigar
sales
um and i i guess i i'm i'm more in line
of a if it helps the business and it
doesn't hurt the state then why would we
oppose this
um if the business can generate more
revenue and can um
can increase again don't forget loose
tobacco and cigarette sales generates
revenue for us um it it seems like it's
a win-win and i'm just not sure why we
wouldn't allow whether it's just one
today it could be five tomorrow and this
may help them tomorrow
i just don't see a downside of passing
this bill i guess is my point is i see
no downside of passing it
rubs
thank you mr chairman i echo those
sentiments and would also like to say
that in the bill it doesn't say that
they can use cigarettes and loose
tobacco inside the cigar bar it says
they can sell it to meet the guideline
that they need to meet uh for their for
their profits in order to be
to be in statute um so
we're not turning it into an entire
smoking establishment with drinks or
food it is still only cigars and maybe
is it pipes too i think
uh but
no i'm talking about what they can
consume currently right now
and uh if they're not going if they're
just using it towards sales it's all
tobacco
whether it's cigar tobacco or it's
cigarette tobacco or loose tobacco or
whatever it's all tobacco
so
i know these are niche
establishments that were
that were put into statute to be able to
do this
but i don't i don't see a downside to
allowing them to have the the full
tobacco sale in there if they're still
only consuming what was originally
appropriated for them
representative aaron
thank you mr chair
so as i understand it the bill is
amended
as amended
allows for the sale of cigar cigarettes
to be included to meet the 60 percent
threshold
that they
have to meet
um they already sell cigarettes but it's
not counted towards or and loose tobacco
but it's not counted towards their 60
so
it's not like they aren't selling the
product already um
i i i actually i don't see a problem
with making the change but um
you know since
it's not like they're
being allowed to sell a product now that
they haven't been allowed to sell
just counts towards their threshold
i guess i'm hearing some of the comments
now i have a question does anybody know
why
why was this law initially put into
place where it was 60 what is the
significance of the 60 percent i don't
know if anybody can answer that
i don't know if anybody can answer that
question well i think i remember
almy
yeah that they
they
the cigar
groups which
we have a representative of right here
had suggested that i believe to
differentiate it
on i think that we should be clear that
we are not talking about whether you can
smoke or
or sell or whatever
this the other kinds of tobacco all
we're talking about is are we going to
loosen the requirements so that
that on
other um cigar stores if they get into
trouble being cigar bars
can still remain as cigar bars because
we've lowered the requirement
for
for the percentage of sales
yes
curtis
do you have something you want to say
any other lobbyists brothers i'll ask
you a question i'll ask you a question
get you going
so
um i think your testimony was that
your
your facilities that you represent
didn't really see a need for this change
uh but i guess the second part of it is
do you have an objection to this change
as i mentioned at the hearing today do
they have an objection right and first
of all mr chairman curtis barry i
represent the cigar association of new
hampshire which is a coalition of five
owners in about a dozen locations
four of which have a cigar bar license
um
no as as i mentioned at the hearing uh
the association had no position on the
bill is introduced has no position
currently either way uh as the bill is
is before the ways and means committee
um and i can attempt to answer
representative nunez's question i think
the philosophy on the 60 was that new
hampshire
does not license or allow
a standalone bar where somebody walks in
and just has a drink so we have a
requirement for a liquor license
currently relative to food you have to
have a certain amount of your sales in
food
um in order to qualify for the liquor
license the philosophy was
you know much the same you needed to do
something you need to be as i put it at
the hearing i think you had to be the
cigar store first and then you could get
a liquor license not the other way
around
thank you
anything else to ask
mr berry
thanks thank you
so
um
then
let me take a stroke let me take a straw
poll
all those that would be in favor of
passing the bill as is raise your hand
okay you twisted my arm here
okay
then it's no big deal i i just don't
like many speakers i'm
sorry i just don't like doing something
fun when it's only one store coming in
that's that's what bothered me the most
that's fine that's fine but if the will
is will i'm i'm on board too
let's get on with it go on to an
executive
representative
mr chair i just was wondering if i could
ask the committee um just briefly you
know i think during one of the hearings
a question was raised about the dras
fiscal note
assertion that a reduction in the
percentage of revenue
a licensee must generate from
non-premium cigar sales is likely to
reduce
the tobacco-related tax revenue
and i recall that there were several
folks on the committee who said
they would like to hear from the dra
as to their explanation for that
assertion
it didn't seem to be to make sense at
the time i believe there was like a
counter-intuitive thought
if you were to reduce the threshold why
would that
reduce tobacco-related tax revenues um
did anybody recall did we get an answer
to that
representative
first it isn't the dra they don't have
anything to do with this
it's the liquor commission
which oversees
on dra a long time ago had something to
do with it but it got moved over
the fiscal notes from liquor commission
yeah
and the second on
i don't
these things are already sold in
most cigar bars i believe
on as a secondary product if somebody
wants some
and so it doesn't seem likely that it's
going to change
tobacco consumption one way or the other
okay
um
i'm going to
open the executive session on house bill
1237.
rob's in a way i move out of pass on
house bill 1237 fn
representative lange
otp
second mr chairman
the second by representative
any further discussion
on the motion of what to pass on house
bill 1237
stand none
ask the koi please call the vote
thank you mr chair
we'll begin the voting on house bill
1237 with a motion about to pass with
representative abrami yes with my arms
slightly twisted yes
representative lange
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
genigean
yes
representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative aaron
yes
representative almi yes
yes thank you
hold on give me one sec
when i say one sec i guess i'm at 45
give me
we're almost there
representative ames yes
representative malloy
yes
the honorable thomas c schomburg
representative schamberg votes yes mr
clerk thank you sir representative
tucker yes representative gomarlo yes
representative hacken phillips
oh yes thank you
representative murphy yes chairman major
yes
the vote being 16 to nothing the motion
about to pass passes
and without objection and go on consent
i see no objection so wrong consent
okay we have one other bill
which is house bill 1584
and representative schoenberg
you passed out your amendment
yes uh the ols has not given us the
unapproved draft yet but this is
the copies
that was sent to them
and it's the ones with the
the holes
punch holes in it
do you all have that
and there was also another copy
i left a single page copy from uh
commissioner jasper
that was also
the explanation
oh
you know what uh
there's there's two amendments yes the
the one
i think it was a missed copy because
they only they put every other page
they put pages one three five
and then left out two and four
that was the one
i'm sorry
mr chairman there was a set that was on
when we came in this morning there was a
set that was on the desk everybody's
desk and then when our our friend from
over here came in he replaced them with
the
holes they didn't match up they didn't
print all the pages yeah they didn't put
the backs of that yes the backs didn't
get printed but the one you have now the
punch holes do
i'm also uh reminded
that representative aaron has an
amendment too
so
so we'll take up representative
sean berger's
amendment first
if you could explain
well uh
as you heard me
in the public hearing end of this
i'm a strong supporter of
county fairs
and
they draw people they bring people into
the community they bring neighbors
together
uh
especially in the where i was from the
state of ohio and i the same thing
happens here also
so in discussion i had brought up
to the commissioner
of moving this to interim study i didn't
want to see it die i wanted to see it
just get
let's get the warning down let's get the
objections
addressed
and the commissioner
he said that's like the kiss of death
the interim study
so
uh
on sunday night i sent
emails to two of the majority prime
sponsors or to the prime sponsor and a
person on the majority side and
the email to the minority sponsor and a
senator on the minority side asking them
to contact someone from the majority
side to see if they would do an interim
study well
with no reply i went to the association
new hampshire affair association and
they contacted the commissioner
and the commissioner on thursday morning
by uh 11 o'clock
emailed this to me
and
i think it's a much better
bill than what was
initially proposed
uh it clears up a lot of questions
and i was trying to find out from the
commissioner why they changed as
representative aaron when she
made up her amendment
why they went from 426
b to
amend rsa 425 19-a and start from there
and
425 is under title 40 it's the
agricultural horticultural animal
husbandry chapter 425 the department of
agricultural markets and food
it was a more
a more
concise and
proper area to have it in and the
commissioner makes the statement that he
uh
says that
they hadn't been using rs842519
for who knows how long
and he said it'd be better just to
replace all the wording
with this amendment
and move forward with
the
suggestions that he has presented
um
i think that that it is a better
amendment
and a better bill
by being amended um
it addressed all the concerns that i had
at the meeting i don't know if it
addressed pres uh
representative bromi's question i'm
trying to find your question here
representative abrami when we had the
discussion
the basic thing is that why is it in
ways and means
well yeah well the issue is going to
become
they have to get an appropriation of 250
000 a year that that that goes year to
year
correct this first finance committee
acts in funny ways you know
i have no problem with creating the
structure the fun
but then it's a crap to choose me
the capital improvement grant program
fund
and i think that's a new one
can you turn your microphones on
sorry i was trying to get it moved out
of the general fund
into
to a one-time
large grant that they could continue to
use but the commissioner totally object
rejected that so
maybe maybe i made other comments i
can't remember now
you know what i recommend on this
since this has been dropped on us today
we really haven't had time to
look at it
and
over the weekend look at it and when we
meet on monday
uh
let's
come up with your comments and
and we should try to get the
commissioner in here
also on monday
as long as we don't mix it with gummy
bears on monday okay
and i would take it up first
mr chairman yes
also this is now
because it would stay as a general fund
appropriation something finance should
have a say in
so
either you're talking over the weekend
i'll i'll talk to karen yes thank you
can we just hear briefly representative
aaron's aaron
represent aaron you want to go through
your amendment sure just briefly um
because after the bill was uh
um
introduced to our committee
i i and
we had testimony on it afterwards during
our lunch break i
got a moment to sit down with
commissioner jasper
and asked him
because some of the questions that came
up was regarding putting a cap on that
fund we didn't want to continually be
putting money in that where it
accumulated and accumulated and he said
to me he was fine if we put a million
dollar cap on this fund
so that's what i wrote up in the first
section of this amendment
and the last section of this amendment
i had also spoken to commissioner jasper
regarding
his
the possibility of him doing some sort
of annual reporting
so i thought that you know it was
reasonable to ask him to do to submit a
report uh annually
which would detail the amount of the
allocations that receive that they
received in what entities received the
allocations and the purposes of the
funds how how they were used and he was
fine with that and and suggested to me
that the report should go to the
president of the senate the chairpersons
of the house and senate ways and means
committee probably should be financed
i said the house and senate finance
committees as well
and the house and senate committees with
jurisdiction over environmental and
agricultural issues and that should be
done
one annually say in november so that was
the gist of the section the second
section
what i'd like to do is
incorporate those ideas into
what representative schomburg has
presented
and i think it's a very good idea
to insert this in chapter 425 of the
statutes because that deals with fund
distributions to agricultural affairs so
makes sense to me
all right so
if you would do that
okay sure
we will uh we both agree
check this up on on
monday
alrighty
and i'll try to i'll get a hold of karen
and see if we can
get
finance participation
they're also going to be meeting at the
same time unfortunately what's that
they're going to be meeting at the same
time so it's going to be a little
difficult
we can work that out
yeah
now
let me ask the committee
what we have left is 1598
plus this one
we're going to deal with on monday
i left it so that we could meet this
afternoon
but
do you think you've heard enough
and then
we'll continue
the work session on 1598 on monday
thank you i think that uh we need to see
the full amendment that needs to come in
from uh from representative lang before
we can really go any further we've we've
beat the original bill to death as
amended so uh i think once we get this
amendment in we make the comparison to
what was and what is we know what we
need to do
thanks for reminding me and very
important yeah um representative lange
how long do you think it will take you
to go through
uh going through it's going to be really
quick having the conversation after we
go through it might be a little bit more
difficult so that
again we've already identified at least
two items that i in my amendment i have
to go get redrafted uh one is the 15
cultivators two is the eight months
uh for rulemaking so i already know i
need to change that why don't you pass
out the amendment and let's go through
it quickly
and then we can chew on it over the
weekend uh ref said major i really need
to have a discussion about this idea of
spreading it to every small farm that
might grow a patch of marijuana
on
it i think if you're going to do that we
at least need i don't know if they're
allowed to get involved with this but
ask the the new hampshire at
extension service yeah unh extensions
to to comment about whether this is at
all feasible it is an annual crop
it
it is highly
uh
vulnerable to droughts to floods
to bad harvesting
to
the quality is the first thing in
marijuana sales
representative ames well i don't
understand much about this but my
understanding is that a lot of cannabis
is cultivated indoor indoors under
lights
anywhere in a house would be fine
so when we talk about small cultivators
in the
marijuana context we're
not talking about the traditional small
farmer i don't think
representative romney okay let's go all
right so
back to the marijuana commission
guess who was in the room a lot in our
meetings
farmers
uh there's nothing in the bill that says
it has to be grown inside or outside
there's no restrictions on it's a
restriction of the 15 which i think we
heard we have to lift that because let
the marketplace
and what when and i had a hallway
conversation with the commissioner
uh he did touch on this that in maine
the liquor commissioner yeah
so the liquor commissioner said
and he's been doing his homework a bit
here and he checked what's going on in
maine
and there are a lot of farm first but
what they do
is they put these we have a lot of that
going on in new hampshire too there's
the one place where in loudoun
that grows
lettuce and greens and things
but it's but it's in the um you know and
it's thin plastic okay right
so that's what you see a lot of
i think that's what he was talking about
that's the way to do it so you can get
more than
one crop a year
so
and i
to me the way the bill is written
and obviously we can amend it to a
degree but but that's kind of so you
know the cross over the policy and our
policy
where we're gonna we're gonna say i
think we're gonna amend out the 15
because
15 is ridiculous for the number of
stores so
that'll impact revenues because we're
going to we're going to constrain the
amount of supply could i ask you a
question i'm not sure i still don't
understand why
we if supply chain is a potential issue
why aren't we growing our own in a very
controlled environment
that wasn't okay
to me it just seems like the logical way
to go in a vertically integrated system
you grow your own greenhouses under
lights whatever it is
right yes i understand that but i'm just
thinking about the control factor coming
from 15 or 20 or 50 different farms from
a from a true recreation model
with commercialization it's a
commercialization model most of these
companies are bigger
and they have vertical integration and
they make money all over every step of
the way from from growing to to
manufacturing to retail
here we're actually putting our
week
if we had that kind of model in the
state i think we could make a lot more
money here
i'm agreeing with you
that
that we're not we're not going to make
any money on the on the cultivation and
if manufacturing comes back into this
bill we're not going to make anything on
manufacturing
because those are going to be private
business but this is the bill that was
handed to us you know i understand this
is and now that's a major amendment to
say
oh no and he he's going to say
we have no expertise in this it's what
the commission is
it's hard enough for him to do what he's
about to do just do the retail
because basically in his business
he they have great experts at buying
things but other manufacturers are doing
all of that
i just think about you know medicines in
general if you bring in a product from
all over the world that isn't controlled
how do you control the end product
that's why to me is more of a question
of just the logic of having
multiple little farms versus growing
your own under control regulated to get
the the same product day in and day out
right but it's it's going to be more
than
little farms it's going to be big and
it's going to be
and if if a small farmer wants to give a
crack at it
you know there'll be a license fee to do
it
they can compete with everybody else
but but you're right about the quality
testing and that's you know i'm just
trying to say you know let the market in
the marijuana commission we said let the
marketplace
sort that all out and we had a long
conversation about this believe me
let's
because we talked about limitations on
growers you know and all that and we
said no you know something like any
other new product
it's going to start here in terms of the
numbers that eventually come down it
sounds like in mass and in maine
it's growing still
so i don't know
we have to remember
that the policy has been set
two to one
by the full house
and we
have to concentrate only on the revenue
part of it
we can't change the policy
representative allow me i i'd like to
address your question about um if i may
mr chair
about the way that it grows we had
testimony and fortunately i have a
little experience in my background with
this uh we had testimony from
the folks from the atc's who
talked about the fact that sometimes
they turn over three to four crops per
year
okay it's in but you wouldn't want to
grow this outside
because if it was outside then people
could come onto your property and take
it and you have better security if it's
inside if it's in a grow house in a
plastic grow house you can provide all
the security you need to that grow house
to make sure that
your product is is secure and safe and
quality and used uh without pesticides
and things that nature
could i just say something to that
on
i think if we put into here something
which
maybe policy but it also quality is
revenue in this case
otherwise they're gonna they're gonna
our people are gonna continue going to
massachusetts
on
that if we put something in that said
that it shall only be grown
inside
i don't know exactly how you'd say
then that will make it
incredibly easier for this
negotiator or whatever
his title is
uh
to actually produce decent quality and
and consistent quality
you would say under the uv lights
under under the under well under the
lights it could be outside if you're
willing to only do two crops a year
but
on
at least on
at that way you aren't worrying about
drought you aren't worrying about about
animals coming in and defecating on it
you're talking about all sorts of things
mr chairman and representative
before i was a legislator i worked with
the u.s virgin islands helping them
craft their medical marijuana policy and
how they would grow it on the island and
of course there they have 12 full hours
of sun every day
and
many of their
many of their crops are grown outdoors
because they have the sunlight and the
needed sunlight that it takes in order
to grow a crop and turn over a crop more
than once annually
and um having said that
in a grow house or in a in a greenhouse
you would put up um a hoop house with uh
you know plastic over it you can control
uh the amount of crop the what you're
going to deliver for crops whatever you
determine three to four a year sometimes
you can get four i know you can get
three
um
indoors inside a greenhouse
uh so with lights
with lights yes with lights and
sometimes without lights i mean you
don't have to have the lights on all the
time in the middle of summer yes yes
let's just talk about pesticides you all
quick though
kidding okay hold on mr chair if i made
it represent aaron and representative
thank you mr chair
so i'm kind of confused about the point
where we talk about
we're only looking at the
financial aspects of this bill and not
the policy aspects and yet
much of the policy aspects really has a
big bearing on the financial aspects
because
here we're talking about well
do we make changes to make this more
profitable for the state such as adding
edibles
do we make
changes to how many suppliers we can
specify and how many licenses the state
can
provide so i i do think to some extent
that we are making some sort of
alterations to policy in order to make
this work financially
is that true okay
it's going to be difficult to separate
the two
but the edibles has been
has been debated
and it's been excluded
but the number of suppliers
i think
we could change that
so um
continue if you've got more questions
um no i i'm just
i'm just sort of struggling with this
issue of um separating out policy from
the finances because they are so much
intertwined and we do want to make this
craft this
any amendments to make this bill
stronger in terms of the argument that
this is going to be
a a worthwhile financial endeavor for
the state to embark upon right and i
agree
for the state to make more money edibles
should be in there
but i think the policy has been set on
that
representative
thank you mr chair and i i guess
i'd like to get into the amendment so
everyone can take it home and read it
for the weekend but i will just make
this statement for me the underlying
policy was legalization
that's the what that's the policy
everything else is the how and the how
is up to us to a certain extent that's
the way i view this is that the wad is
fine we've legalized it now the question
is how do we go about doing that and
that has revenue implications and that's
why we can have discussions around how
many cultivators there are and those
kind of things it gets to the to the how
so that's the way i view this and that's
why in drafting some of this stuff i'm
i'm looking at it that way i like that
so if i get into the amendment
so everybody can kind of get a sense of
what it looks like there were some
significant changes yes um
so
i'm going to start on the first real
change is on page five
of the amendment
um
so
i have a i already have the draft to
change page five line 28. this is about
the regulations and to representative
ames point i added the word licensure on
line 30
and i have a new amendment version going
in that will change
sorry a little slower i apologize okay
we're on page five
page five line
[Music]
can you get backwards
yeah they ols the health committee
services stapled it backwards so
apologize for that although it does make
it easy to read
um until page five yeah well and you're
reading forward
so
so at page five so if you pull up page
five
we're on line 28
so based on the committee conversation
today i'm going to change that december
1 for
december 1 2022 to read
eight months after the passage of this
bill
so it gives the committee so once the
governor signs it the clock starts
ticking they have eight months from
whatever that date is
that's line 28 where it says december
1st 22 i'm going to change that take the
date out and say no later than eight
months after the passage of this bill
the next change was on 30.
i think we're going to discuss it on
monday i think i'm just trying to get it
to everybody so everybody can know what
the changes are
and we don't want to just
we'll discuss
the length on
monday on line 30 at representative ames
request we added registration licensure
and regulation so i added the word
licensure in there
on line 30
page five line 30 number roman numeral
number one it says we added the word
licensure before it's before it just
said registration and regulation and we
added regulation uh registration
licensure and regulation right this this
was from the subcommittee that was from
the subcommittee there was a request for
representatives
um
[Music]
what else would i get next the next one
is on page seven and this is a mistake
that drafting is fixing
uh so we'll come out in the new bill on
line number three of page seven roman
numeral
four six there
um what that meant to say but they made
it that the atc's become retail stores
and that wasn't what we intended
um what we intended to do was to allow
the atcs to be able to get a parallel
license for cultivation
manufacture
and um
transportation of cannabis so that they
could sell to the state because under
the current rules they can't do that so
we have to amend the law to allow them
to be able to sell to the state because
of their not-for-profit status
that is well it's gonna show up in on
page seven line three roman numeral six
it says the alternative treatment center
is registered to operate on pursuant to
rsa blah blah blah this says that
uh shall obtain a separate registration
to operate a cannabis establishment
pursuant to this chapter and yet we
meant to say they could be cultivators
um manufacturers and um
delivery agents so that was in response
to their concern about being harmed and
you were going to say if they said that
they could sell as well then that
wouldn't hurt their atc therapeutic
model correct it was an olive branch yes
it was an olive branch to that
organization to give them an another
revenue stream to keep them healthy
right okay they actually had no position
so it's
it's my understanding on that
correct committee
or can i
well
right right right but we'll talk to them
we can talk about it so then if we go
over to page eight
so this is where the banking language
was originally in this bill and we
struck all of the banking language that
was originally put into the bill however
we did add some language in here about
banking and one of it had to do with
if you look at line
the big thing is we just we talk about
having to separate the funds from
cannabis from all other state funds so
if something happens we're not putting
the entire general fund at risk
somehow because it's co-mingled monies
um and so it talks about the fact that
the um the money's being credited to a
fund that will be held distinct and
separate from all other funds
um under the straight treasurer's
control so is that a one a roman that's
1a okay they're cannabis control fund
correct under under yeah starting on
line 18 number one
uh a
the languages we added some language in
air just to keep the funds separate you
got this language from the
from the new hampshire bankers
association from the association and i
ran it by the liquor commission they
were completely okay with it right okay
and then b is also a mechanism to take
money out of there for the state if
there is ever enough money we'll get the
disbursements a little bit later in the
amendment
um the second line again is is just some
banking language to clean up um to make
sure the state's doing it right we
talked about with the finn sin
and the flag
page what line again we're on the same
page page eight the next section b
not withstanding and provision of lower
contrary financial institutions with a
branch within the state so again minor
banking language it again was from the
new hampshire banking association that
would clean up the language and also i
ran this by liquor commission and they
were okay with it
okay now we get into a disbursement of
funds from this fund
um
so where's that same same page we're at
line we're going to start at line number
30 and i just want to have before we
start reading the actual bill i want to
tell you exactly what i did and then
i'll show you how the chat how it plays
out
under the original bill the first
disbursement we made was to pay back the
taxpayers for the startup costs
a little bit of problem with that is
that they need to be able to operate so
it didn't take enough money in and we
used all the money to pay back the state
they had no money to run the rest of the
stores for any time so i inverted number
one and two and i said the first thing
they do is get to take their operational
operation expenses out then they'll pay
back the citizens
uh we're at we're on page eight line
thirty
and i'm just reading it it'll start it
it all runs right starting at thirty
everything i'm saying will run down from
there on to page nine but i just want to
explain what i did so you have to read
every language we can fix the language
later if you don't like it um so the
first thing i did was invert the payment
to the citizens the general fund back
for the startup cost with the operating
costs so the first line is they get to
take their operating costs out which
allows them to be able to use that as a
revolving fund to be able to
add funds into their operational
expenses to open the next store and so
they can get to their stores without
having to take another loan from the
state to open more stores so they can
use their operating revenues to be able
to slowly roll out more stores after the
initial expenditure
i did put um at the
recommendation of ols that they have a
five-year timeline to pay back the
citizens so they have five years to pay
back the money that we use to get we
give them to start the uh start the ball
rolling
and that's in line um
that's on line 35 no later than
june 30 to 2027 the commission shall
reimburse the general fund so again it's
a no later then so that if they get all
their stores up in three years and the
next year they have they're flush with
cash they can pay the whole thing off in
the fourth year and it's done but they
have to have it done by the fifth year
and they can interject so mr chair so
you did this because
the they requested while in the bill it
was 14 million
actually they the liquor commission
thought it should have been even more
14 million now became 5 million or four
point whatever
and that that uh
and that the only way we can finance
the new stores was to do this to give
them time to pay back the initial loan
right and it gives them lets them use
their operating revenue that they create
to be able to open more stores until we
get the full
10 and then we're at our full-blown 50
million dollars or whatever 30 million
dollars in revenue and they'll easily be
able to pay the citizens back but it was
a it's like any startup business right
you got to have some revenue coming in
if you want to grow
you know so we got to give them that
ability to grow to get where where they
need to be
um
so that's that as we roll into page
eight now or nine
so in the first two sections on on page
eight we allow them to
take out their operating expense and
then pay back the state within five
years
now we have what i consider the we had
the gross net which is what we were
talking about there now we come to the
net net
this is after we've taken the
operational expense out any monies that
we decide to pay back to the general
fund we have this new revenue
that total and um uh
so from that revenue total the net net
um
um of those of the funds that are left
will go to offset this the 363 million
dollars we raise for the swept tax
i'm sorry line three
starting at line three yes i'm sorry yep
line three page nine
so fifty percent of the remaining
balance will be dispersed annually the
department of revenue to be dispersed
the cities and towns to offset the
educational property tax imposed by on
persons blah blah blah so again the idea
is that
i'll use some simple round numbers if we
had 50 million dollars
we would take 25 million dollars we
immediately lower what was needed to be
raised by taxation from swept from 363
million dollars down to 363 minus 25
million so we raised less money on the
individual citizens that on the prop on
the swept property tax line just just uh
note
because we'll be discussing this on
monday
that i do not think that's a wise
allocation it skews heavily towards the
property wealthy towns
uh maltenborough will get gobs of cash
and
charlestown and jeffrey will get very
little okay so you have that comment i
knew i knew that was going to be a
conversation point uh but again that's
that's
so we can talk i actually don't know
numbers i don't wha
representative ames and i talked about
this i don't want to get bogged down in
the conversation but i'm a little
confused how that plays out a little bit
myself
so we can talk about that later let me
stop this right now
we're here to listen to where the
changes are and what they are
and then so that we can
understand these over the weekend and
come back monday and then move on
questions and comments thank you mr
chair so the next change is we allocated
30 percent of the net net
to pay off the new hampshire retirement
system debt
to try to expedite that faster
which would be a huge benefit to our
cities and towns if we can get there
quicker
less less interest we pay on that debt
the more
and immediately both the towns and the
employees would see a benefit because
their percentage of retirement costs
would drop and that would result in more
money in their paycheck versus going to
retirement so we allocated 30 percent of
those funds that are remaining to go to
the new hampshire retirement system debt
specifically and once we pay off that
debt three that 30 percent will go
directly to the education trust fund
the next item is 10
or 25 million whichever is less so we
get to the point where we're making 200
and or 300 million dollars in net net
which would be great
dhhs would the cessation programs would
be held to a 25 million dollar cap
but we also allow it so as the program
ramps up dhhs in theory would have more
need and therefore they would get more
money
as the program ramps up the money to
dhhs would ramp up
the last two item the last two five
percents are five percent will go to
public safety agencies again the
anticipation here is things like police
standards and training council would be
able to offer
drug recognition expert classes to allow
law enforcement officers to better
understand what does drug driving look
like
and be able to recognize those kind of
symptoms and the problems that are
coming up
and the last one is five percent which
is the last five percent of the net net
uh shall be dispersed the department
health and human services behavioral
health um bureau of children children's
behavioral health to be used why we need
finance with us on monday right so and i
ran these again i ran all of this by
finance um and they actually really
loved the idea we were giving new
hampshire retirement system money to pay
that debt off faster
i ask good question
just a clarification question so if
you've just allocated 100
where's the money to open a new store so
that's the net net so we talked about
gross debt the top we start with the
gross net which is 50 million dollars if
we use their original numbers
right the first thing we take out of
that is their operating expense the
second thing we take out of that any any
dollar amount they want to use to pay
off the startup and now you're left with
the net net now we're doing percentage
of that net net
just ask on that i thought that what you
did
was stop taking out money for the new
stores after night
after uh
27.
no they have to pay back the startup
costs to the to the general fund by
2027.
but then anything that they want to keep
to open new stores
which is something we've seen a lot with
liquor that they
that our revenues go down because they
they open new stores so if i made the
way i understand we do current liquor
stores is that they do it out of their
operating costs so they don't they
collect their revenue and then they
project out we want to open this store
it's good we're going to charge this
expense it would go to their operating
expenses so it would come out of the
first line when they open a store it's
going to be part of the operating
expenses they're deducting out of the
gross net exactly but it does
continually come out we will discuss
that on monday
the next change is on page 9 line 33 and
this is where we had the that just the
typo they had um temporary investigators
something like that and i'd change it to
market consultants on line 33. and that
is the
negotiant the negociant yes
no they wanted market consultants they
were okay with that actually
negotiate was apparently
all also doing all of the
the uh
visiting of the farms and making sure
that that
their quality was
sufficient
again the marketing consultants may do
all of that that's within whatever so
the all the bill does is allow them to
create an rfp to say we want to we want
a market consultant and they can define
within the market consultant what all
the conditions and scope of work is so
go ahead
um
[Music]
where else am i here
actually i'm pretty close to done mr
chair i think the only thing i have left
to change
is on page 10 and this is based on the
conversation we had here online number
26 and that's the 15
the limit on the 15 cultivation
cannabis cultivators facilities so i'll
strike that language if everyone's in
agreement with that and leave it for the
free market to be able to adapt and
adjust
26.
on page
i think that's very nice and i believe
that is it i will say there is one
question that was brought up and this is
about the underlying this is a policy
question i gotta get answered
um there was a question on whether or
not the language that the criminal
justice committee did accidentally
really re illegalized edibles
and i'm going to try and get an answer
to that question but i think they in
trying to clean up do with the language
they somehow undid the other language we
did in previous years when we
decriminalized certain things and they i
think when they did their edit they
might have added it back in so i'm going
to look at that and i'll talk to the
chairman of criminal justice to confirm
that and take care run that down mr
chairman if i may that was brought to us
by hhs
the the
our visitor and subcommittee from hhs
said that that this bill may
may strike our current decrim law and
the last thing that we want to do is
strike out anything that would hurt
decrem on the edible side on the on on
that side that may not be coming into
our store we don't want to we don't want
to step on that law
right so mr j one last thing if i can
just run through the numbers considering
that's probably the thing we hear most
important about based on the
conversations we had with the
commissioner so people can write down
the numbers and see if they all we can
all agree on what a fiscal outlook looks
like for this thing
so i'm using i'm basing everything off
we all have this form that was given to
us by the commission itself that has the
revenues on it it's about the third or
fourth paragraph down where they
estimated that based on the tens the new
hampshire would have about 250 million
dollars in gross revenue for the state
that gross revenue number would gener
turn into approximately 50 million
dollars in net in in gross net revenue
to the tax to the state to spend
um but we also know
that of that 50 million dollars
that included edibles in their
projections now that's no longer in
there so out of that 50 million dollars
you've got to strike 40 percent or 20
revenue coming in to the state
we also know that we're going to be
rolling these stores out slowly
roughly one-third
a year
so for the first year full operating
year we expect the revenue to be 10
million dollars one third of the thirty
million dollars so our income in the
first year first full calendar year of
operations with one third of the stores
open should be around ten million
dollars
um
we know on the cost side
of this that they estimated the annual
cost for 10 stores
was 10 stores and the personnel was 8.5
million dollars
we have to divide that by one-third per
year roughly
um so i was trying to get them finished
up that math so it's one third of 8.5
million dollars so again even in the
first year taking in 10.5 million
dollars um their costs are only going to
be around roughly 3 million dollars so
we'll see revenue generation to the
state uh on on a
gross net level so what what they can
actually um or distribute to towns and
cities of around um
three million dollars
or so um
for the startup that's after with just
three stores open and then those numbers
are i'm sorry i apologize the number is
10.5 million dollars in the first year
and that number will grow as the stores
grow
so i just want to give you some basic
numbers where we're at even in the first
year they should be profitable with 30
stores and give them enough money to
start rolling it back into the agency to
be able to open the other stores
would you put that into a i will put it
into an email and distribute to the
entire committee
there is one other thing on revenues
yeah
one other thing on revenue is that
darrell abbas emailed me yesterday and
he sent a copy to fred de set and tim
lang i probably you haven't
i got it this morning but i'll take a
look at it and see how his numbers
compared to everything else we talked
about forward that to all the members
and
it was an analysis done for
massachusetts in order to come up with
numbers for new hampshire
and i want you to take a look at that
i'll get that out to you today
but they come out 40 to 50 million
dollars
mr chair could i just say one last thing
yes thank you so this isn't necessarily
a ways and means thing but again i i
look at this in this conversation about
we have the the what and the how
and for me the what is the most
important conversation we're having and
the how just gets us there right and
when i say that what i mean is
legalization to me is the most important
thing and i am holding my nose when i
vote for this thing i i'm not
don't necessarily like the way it's done
at all
but my ultimate goal is to stop
arresting our citizens
stop crim get making criminals out of
our citizens
for this product which i don't think is
any more dangerous than beer or wine and
actually i'd argue it's probably less
dangerous than beard wine
considering the number of domestics i've
been as a police officer for beer and
wine compared to marijuana which was
zero
um and so i don't want everybody to get
caught up right in in arguing over the
how right we got to get if we if our
goal if we our
goal is to achieve
legalization and to stop arresting our
citizens stop incarcerating our citizens
stop making criminals out of our
citizens
it's going to involve compromise
we're going to have to hold our nose and
vote for something i'm going to hold my
nose and vote for this when we get to a
final things even if we decide to change
the financial makeup from what i
suggested i'll hold my nose and i'll
vote for it because
again it's the what that's the most
important thing stop arresting our
citizens stop making criminals out of
our citizens
and let's move forward
right and myself personally i would have
to hold my nose twice
because
by doing this
you're telling our youth this is
perfectly acceptable
and i don't think anybody here that's a
parent
would want to encourage their kids to
use marijuana or these edibles
but our job here is
because the policy was set
we need to look at this bill
from a financial aspect
make it as good as we can for the state
of new hampshire and
not exceed
what's not in there
and
then bring it to the floor
i probably
well anyway i'll make my mind up then
but but we need to do our job
make it as best as we can
with
good revenue projections on this
you had something to say
well i mean we are the how committee
even though
tim you're right
that the criminal justice was the other
committee that said this is the policy
i'm sure decriminalization
decriminalization
of it was part of their reasoning but
that's what we do how and we are fixing
the bill
so um
i do have one other comment about the
edibles
is that one other thing we have to
address i think i think the chair made
it clear that we're not going to put
edibles back in
but the one thing about edibles we have
to discuss i still think is
whether they should be sold to
why do we have it in there that atc
atc
patients with a card can go in and
expect to see edibles that's that's a
ridiculous situation you should ask the
commissioner i talked to him offline
about this
so how does that work how do we how do
we have
uh edibles on the shelves but most of
their customers coming in so you can't
can't have those
so i think we should take the atc
portion out of it
in terms of
as an alternative because it's going to
hurt the atc's too
is it did i say that clearly
yes i completely understand what you're
saying and i completely you know we have
this conversation in subcommittee we
have basically three options we remove
the medical edibles and they're not
there we leave them in there or we just
barge ahead and leave recreational and
put recreational edibles in i will tell
you the last one's a show stopper for
some for some people in this process um
as it moves through the legislative
process so um what's the showstopper
having recreational edibles in the state
store as a showstopper for for uh
somewhere in the other two pieces of
chain this has to go um and so uh again
um so again you know
whether we include recreational or
medicinal is the question right and and
i can have when i finish getting the
final draft i can have them draft two
versions one striking medical and one
leaving medical in and we can choose
between those two
uh versions or if we could
just have a
strong vote right now
do you wanna have discussion on that
yeah it's time to vote oh what's that
right now
just have a straw vote right now to see
if we're mostly on the same page
about that
so i i just have one if we're going to
do that i just have a statement i would
have waited till monday but
we're going to wait some months okay
okay can i
ask two
revenue questions about
edibles one is
when you went into subcommittee
we
had 50
edibles
and for the revenues
now it's 40
and
we did have those maine people uh
who are here who
explained something that i thought was
perfectly reasonable that they take the
lower quality marijuana that
that
they grow that doesn't work quite and
those go into the edibles
which would increase the
decrease about the
which would make it more
than the 40 percent i don't know where
the 40 came from i'd just like to know
if i may
so that originally started from
representative abrami gave us uh in in
the committee from the original bill
were having a conversation he had gone
online and did some research and i i
think actually we're we're goofing now
that i'm thinking about it because as
the commissioner said
vaping isn't considered an edible
right so that was 26 percent i took out
to get to the 40 40 so
it's 18 edibles and ingestibles are 18
or 20
vaping and ointments are not edibles
right exactly so you'd allow pre-rolls
accessories topicals flour cartridges
and concentrates the only thing you
wouldn't allow was basically gummies and
cookies and brownies
so
you better do is double check with the
the the hidden person there
because exactly we we're we've kind of
grouped in edibles and ingestibles
with some of these other pre-rolls which
are a big thing now
people don't want to roll their own like
they buy them already and they're all
consistently done
uh accessories it's not a big topicals
which is very minor the the just like
that you put on your arm you know
absorbs it as scandal it's more medical
right flour is your traditional that's
the loose marijuana that you roll your
own and then cartridges is a big thing
which is you know it's it's the vaping
devices that that have marijuana you
know
thc in them
and then the concentrates are 14 percent
that that's according to this
study uh this report that i found
so
so what do we
i think the bill needs to well we should
define the stuff in the bill in a way
as to what we're talking about
because concentrates and i'm sure the
cartridge manufacturers make car
cartridges concentrates or they extract
the stuff out of the out of the flour
and they create and probably the stem
too
i think when i re-read the bill
that's what i realized actually the
vaping cartridges were allowed even
though we took them out in our financial
calculations thinking how much it was
going to be
but
in the bill itself it doesn't actually
prohibit it and so it just
it prohibits edibles which i mean that
you know what you take orally but then
if you can still convoluted but then we
need manufacturers who are going to come
in and manufacture certain things
so we're going to say well we're going
to try to attract manufacturers to
manufacture the cartridges for us
you know what i mean let's say
i i don't quite know how that works but
you know use it you'll manufacture
everything the way i look at it it'd be
like any other supply chain right if i
go to a store i may not buy everything
the store sells but i'm gonna take what
i want so if a man we have a
manufacturer's license
or in this case we're gonna allow the
atcs to sell so they may
ramp up their vaping side of their
cartridges and not touch their gummy
bears right they're gummies because
um they don't they know they don't have
a state outlet for that so but they do
have a state outlet for cartridges so
they're going to ramp up excuse me okay
bernstein wants to say something
followed by representative spillsberg
yeah thank you mr chair i mean we are um
there's a lot to consider over the
weekend and there's been some people
sitting in the room all morning with
some a lot of expertise and i would love
to let them briefly
perhaps give us more to think about over
the weekend and hear some comments
if if you if with the indulgence of the
chair
does anybody there have comments that
they want to share with a committee
okay
can i answer one question
anybody else out there
i think the banking's going to disappear
yeah they they but they came up with the
language that's in the bill for the
raise done okay
that looks pretty standard to me
representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman yeah before we get
into the
delve down other paths i just
i don't know whether this is really
important to say or not but
philosophically one thing i think we
should all be baking into our thinking
over the weekend
is that
i think as legislators we're accustomed
to work in a domain
of regulation and fees and taxes and to
try to
create a structure with uncertainty with
a lot of certainty
or as much as we can anticipate
but we're dealing with a situation here
also where we're we're creating an
enterprise and an enterprise requires a
lot of flexibility and freedom
uh trial and error
learning through the process
entrepreneurial spirits and so on so the
bill has to be
find the balance
between creating a regulatory regime
that doesn't go off the rails
but also allowing enough flexibility in
the operating uh environment
to actually compete to price
to work out relationships uh and i i
think uh the takeaways for example from
the fellows from maine who testified
is in in the practical reality of
running an enterprise
there are a lot of decisions that may be
made on the fly
may be made to adjust from experience
and so let's not tighten it down so hard
that that can't happen
soccer
this is a really boring question but
the coast county delegation is going to
vote on its annual budget on monday
so could you tell me what your plan is
for next week you're not going to exact
until wednesday
what i was
hoping but
that may not happen
i was hoping that we could
exact on monday i mean i'm happy to give
up going to the annual budget but i need
to be able to tell the chairman after
this discussion
i think we're going to spend a long time
monday
ironing these things out
but monday we're going to take care of
house bill
1584 first it shouldn't take long and
after we take care of that and we'll
spend the rest of the time
on monday
and if we're not satisfied
then
on wednesday we will
but if you are satisfied you would you
exact on monday yes
okay so i'll be here again
mr chairman
i don't want to miss the executing of
this bill
okay so that's my time and i can't
promise that that's going to happen i
understand
yeah
anybody else perhaps online i just want
to say anybody who has have to read the
amendment over the weekend has
suggestions or changes especially if
they're just simple changes if you can
get them to me so that up monday i can
actually have a a draft you know of the
minor changes that we we all see or feel
um and then it'll give us a better
starting point rather than trying to
merge them all together in the middle of
a
i'm sorry say that again
you'll have fresh copies of this i will
have fresh copies i already know we've
made two or three changes just in our
conversations today from what i had put
in so if you have more uh that are the
cleanup language or that kind of thing
just please email me and i'll try to get
them into ols so that on monday when we
go to meet we have a nice clean copy
with all suggested amendments and
representative aaron and representatives
south uh
schanburg
will get their
amendments squared away
together okay good
representative elmi thank you i mean we
did this a little while ago and i was
trying to
on
representative
uh clerk who is head of the atc
oversight committee
has told me that they are totally
opposed to vaping
so don't
and
confirm that if you want i don't know if
anybody's here
but
otherwise
don't put that in and
i hope we're going to get all of this
emailed to us so that we can print it
out and figure out
what for instance what the numbers are
because it looked to me like part of it
was backwards
and i just probably wasn't following it
representative romney i think i think mr
simon can
i think mr simon can help us with one or
two things while he's here i think we
should take advantage of that okay
you want to represe do you want to start
with representative romney's question
yes thank you
just to clarify the medical oversight
board i've attended all of their
meetings they did adopt a formal
position which if i may
try to replicate it off the top my head
was any adult use any legalization bill
to do adult use cannabis
should be evaluated on on the basis of
its impacts on the therapeutic cannabis
program
that program is important and needs to
be maintained that's the only formal
position the medical oversight board has
taken i know that some of the
medical professionals on that board have
personally strong feelings about vaping
but that has not been discussed at any
of the public meetings and they have not
taken a position that i'm aware of on
that
okay but i do not think you should be
trying to say that they should start
selling vaping products without talking
to them
and you have
answers to any other
i was going to comment on a couple other
things thank you for the record matt
simon representing prime atc
and i thank you again for your time on
monday i'm encouraged by a lot of the
things i'm hearing overall
i was encouraged by the liquor
commissioner's testimony saying that we
need more cultivation licenses because
as i said on monday this is not going to
be a successful market if you only have
a very small number of cultivators and
so that's that's all very encouraging
i would reiterate that our position on
the bill is opposed as currently written
and we will have to evaluate this
amendment and have attorneys look at it
before we can get back to you with a
position on it
what's the opposite
why are you opposing it well we are
supportive of legalization and we've
supported other legalization bills uh
certainly note hb 629's already passed
the house so when we talk about
stopping arrests the house has already
passed a bill
that does that so i think this is
something entirely different and we
believe that to create a market for
cannabis is something that should be
done thoughtfully and deliberately and
with a
great knowledge base and i think the
bills that were based on the study
commission's recommendations uh
really created a much more thoughtful
policy
than this bill i think as it passed the
original committee in the house
originally it was an unworkable bill i
think that became clear to many of you
at the public hearing and you're now
trying to make it workable so we support
that process we want to help you make it
workable in case it does pass so that it
is is a as good a policy as we can make
it but currently it's very far from from
what we believe would be ideal
legalization policy so
did you follow along with the amendment
as proposed by i did so the biggest
thing that i see uh
is
that
while it does clarify that the htc's
could
apply for adult use licenses it does not
authorize us to convert to for-profit
businesses so essentially what you would
be doing if this passed as i understand
it
would be inviting uh
if well it would have been 15
cultivators under the bill if it's not
amended if it's amended to unlimited
licenses
either way you're going to be saying
for-profit companies are welcome to
establish in new hampshire and atc's yes
you can compete for with them that you
have to remain a non-profit and
therefore you won't be able to access
capital and you will be operating at a
massive disadvantage so we think that's
fundamentally unfair uh if the atcs
aren't able to compete on a level
playing field against these new
businesses
uh i don't understand how we could
support that it's just not fair
mr chair just to respond to that that
was not the intent the intent was we'd
have a parallel for-profit license
and apply so um and be able to use the
same facilities so without having to
recreate the wheel so to speak so i did
talk to anthony about that he's trying
to clean that language up over an ols
but the intention was to have you to be
able to get a parallel for-profit
license to be able to use your
cultivation facilities to sell to the
state for what you're growing
okay
i appreciate that i have no idea how it
would work and that's the kind of thing
on that but
just can i just we got to clean that up
with a second mr chair
so you said license but but we're
talking about incorporation
that they want to incorporate as a
for-profit
is that in the language
so again the the intention would be just
like following any of the other lang any
other provisions under the licenses that
are granted here they would just have to
form a corporation that's for profit and
be able to apply for a license and and
state
and we'd be allowing if i could finish
we'd be allowing basically that their
current facilities could be used for
both the not-for-profit and for-profit
services
my understanding mr chair
chair is that we had a there was a bill
right that didn't make it through to do
that correct senate bill 38 uh was
vetoed last year it was veto right two
votes short of the override in the house
yeah
so so it passed it passed the house on
the senate senate in the house
yeah senate house correct but the
governor vetoed it okay so so
again that's enough so again this isn't
the retail side so we're not letting
them sell we're letting them cultivate
manufacture and transport to the state
on a for-profit basis
okay representative
uh and uh thank you mr chairman to add
to that i think there are other
discussions that are going on with other
processes
that are okay with that but we'll see
when we get there on that um i want to
switch gears for just a moment if i can
and
and ask mr simon thank you so much for
being here because i think that your
knowledge is
is the wealth that we're looking for um
mr simon
would you please explain to the
committee
about vaping cartridges about vaping and
how it comes from flour and or
concentrate in or because you i know
that you have a lot of information about
this and i think this is confusing when
we talk about vaping
people don't know that you can put the
flour inside a pen
and it heats it up and then you take in
the vape
so that's just like
it's better for you i think than smoking
a joint
i'm sorry i'm a little crass i apologize
uh but could you could you explain that
just a little bit for us
uh yeah are you talking about whole
flower vaping is that what you mean and
differentiating that between when we
usually talk about
vaping and certainly in the context of
nicotine people are
familiar with the e-cigarettes they have
little heating elements batteries they
heat the chamber the liquid is heated
you inhale the vapor it's healthier than
smoking because there's no tar there's
no carbon monoxide
the other by-products of combustion are
not present so it's a cleaner product uh
the same sorts of
vape cartridges are made using cannabis
oil and you'll see those pretty commonly
in in the marketplace and uh frankly
there are unregulated hemp derived
thc vapes that you can buy in any vape
shop in new hampshire and they're
psychoactive and i think they should be
part of this discussion about how we
regulate cannabis and so far they
haven't been but people are very
familiar with the idea that oil is is in
cartridges but people also as a
representative suggests vape the whole
flower which can be done by grinding it
up and putting it in essentially there
are these different types of vaporizers
that have different types of heating
elements some of them have fan some of
them don't but the whole point is it
heats the flower up to a temperature
that is below the point of combustion it
releases the cannabinoids you're able to
inhale the thc and the other
cannabinoids without tar carbon monoxide
and that's something that a lot of our
patients at prime
is how they prefer to consume flour but
as far as this bill goes that would all
be under flour whether it's used
smoked whether it's vaporized in the
manner i just described or if somebody
buys flour and makes their own edibles
out of it or something like that it
would all be under that same category
thank you mr chairman for the follow-up
uh mr simon that
does do the atcs consider
concentrates
such such as those other types of vaping
materials
also part of the flower industry
is that an easy enough question or is
that too convoluted
i mean generally the way we look at it
is
pretty much tracks with how our
regulators look at it uh and and our
regulators have a category called
cannabis infused products
and that is a broad category that that
encompasses all of all the infused
products so there's flour and then
there's
cip cannabis infused products so if this
is going to move forward i would suggest
that some of the definitions in in the
amendment of the bill need to be
adjusted to match the existing
therapeutic cannabis program for example
the word medical isn't in in the medical
cannabis bill it is a therapeutic
cannabis bill
patients don't use cannabis for medical
use they use it for therapeutic use
it is a written certification not a
prescription things like that would need
to be trued up to the existing policy
so
edibles
is not in the same
box
as
let's say the
vaping
and other
edibles is
something you put in your mouth and your
chew
most people would agree with you i'm
just saying that under our rules of the
therapeutic cannabis program cannabis
infused products include edibles and
also include vape cartridges
because they're all infused
mr chair
can i just ask mr simon if you wouldn't
mind shoot me an email with some of the
definition things that'll clean up some
of the language and i'll look at that
and see if we can integrate it into the
bill into the amendment okay certainly
further comments or questions
no i think
and then representative brownie
followed by representative tucker so
i don't know if you saw the list i had
so we had edibles injector and
ingestibles
which in some state includes
sodas
things like that
yes so and soda
sorts of things right right and some
states have it in beer but but i think
the commit
i know sure was studying this in the in
the commission that was beer and i we
said no make sure it doesn't go into
beer although in this case with the
liquor commission it makes sense but
but so we got pre-rolls
so pre-rolls how popular is that getting
well i i i not not just so not
necessarily in your your
your world but the recreational world
yeah so those are the kinds of questions
that i would ask our ceo and ceo they
could give us exact numbers if we wanted
them what they are in our market and i
could tell you what they are in other
markets but i'm i'm not a i'm not a
marketplace
expert i'm not a grower and i'm not a
you know i'm the pr guy in the lobbyist
and i i've been all through the
facilities i've asked a million
questions but there's a lot that i don't
know
so this is
the only accessories that would be that
would be outside of this
they the stores would sell accessories
but they would get from other kind of
manufacturers so right that's very small
percentage topicals that's the ointments
that that absorb through the skin
and that's a very small percentage
flour is the cartridges we just talked
about
and concentrates so it concentrates the
dabbing stuff right you take its waxes
you put it in this heating device and
it's
you wanna explain how that works you
could probably do a better job than i
can on that sure
so yeah the the most potent forms of
cannabis that are available to consumers
are concentrates uh they you know
they're readily available in the
massachusetts and maine markets you'll
see them with thc concentrations uh into
the 90 percentile and above
and and the appeal of these products is
you know as opposed to if you're a
regular consumer of cannabis and you
have a high tolerance you don't want to
smoke a whole joint every time you're
going to get
looking for the effect that you're
looking for
if i make the analogy to beer you
wouldn't want to drink 12 beers if it
took you 12 beers to get the buzz that
you want so some people prefer to sip
bourbon
it's healthier because there
are fewer carbs and less less impurities
you're getting the pure substance
so the way these products work you you
either
they're a variety of devices that will
reach the desired temperature you take a
small amount of the concentrate touch it
to the device and it releases the vapor
that you then inhale
and the appeal is that it's
more pure and and
achieves the effect very quickly without
the impurities and the smoke involved
with smoking
she had her
thank you mr chair
so the question about um with with the
products that are sold either through
the
nonprofits or just in general
are there any labeling requirements that
are placed on these products with so far
as
how they might affect somebody's blood
pressure or
interfere with any other medications
they may be taking or
pregnancy or any of that any kind of
labeling requirements that you have to
deal with
yes so the department of health and
service human services has adopted
detailed rules uh all of our products
are required to be independently lab
testing lab tested
for the potency the cannabinoid profile
so all of the labels include the
cannabinoid profiles how much thc how
much cbd how much cbn how much cbg
things like that it's also independently
lab tested for impurities including
microbials
heavy metals pesticides it's one of the
major marketplace concerns when you have
unregulated cannabis and frankly the
biggest issue in maine is that while
they are requiring independent lab
testing for their adult use market and
they have this robust caregiver driven
medical market where independent lab
testing is optional so it's one of the
concerns that we have it's one of the
reason maine medical cannabis is so much
cheaper is they don't have that
requirement so a lot of new hampshire
patients are going to maine for the
cheaper
products but the labels minimally have
all the cannabinoids and certifies that
it does not have the the impurities that
it passed the testing on that now
brought more broadly to your question
we've
worked with our regulators and with the
medical oversight board we've developed
educational materials on on questions
such as
cannabis use while breastfeeding
cannabis use during pregnancy
cannabis used by minors any other issue
that is important because we understand
that our patients are very often
beginning with a very low
knowledge level in many cases they've
never tried cannabis they're coming to
us for help to to use it
and get the effects that they want
and they're not looking to get
stoned for the most part they're looking
to feel better and we want to help them
do that and make sure they're aware of
any potential
negatives so we have a lot of
educational materials that are geared
toward that and we encourage every
patient that registers
to come in for a consultation especially
if they're not familiar with cannabis to
sit down with one of our staff members
talk about what their goals are what
they hope to achieve through their
cannabis use and what products uh and
what regimen might be most beneficial
for them
okay can i representative so
so
here's my kids what i'm still not
certain about
edibles i'm just going to use this from
i got this from flow hub
18 was edibles and injectables
but then down the bottom we have 26
percent of cartridges
and we have 14 percentage concentrates
that we just talked now that we kind of
define the terms
and then flour was 33 percent and then
then it was for minor for the pre-rolls
were seven percent
so i'm assuming that
you're vertically integrated correct
so you do the growing you have you do
the manufacturing job so
which is probably a better business
model than we're talking about here
because you kind of make
not that you're a for-profit but
it is
it cascades down and and unless even in
the recreational markets that are a lot
of those are are vertically integrated
they make money at each step of the way
here
we're going to have private companies
making they have to make a profit for
growing and the manufacturers which and
i have one more question to
manufacturers but manufacturers they're
going to make some money along the way
so for this to retail we're not going to
make as much much money as if we were
vertically integrated we're not even we
can't even consider that because that
policy is set that it's just going to be
retail we're going to private enterprise
for the other two
so
um
my concern is
how how are we going to track
manufacturers
i see i'm not sure if we're going to
sell on the stars from the current the
policy language that was given to us
technically we're not doing edibles and
injectables other than people the way
the bill stands right now without our
corrections
edibles and injectables
and ingestibles okay so i'm not aware of
any injectable
no no no
ingestibles
it's
edibles edibles
without
eating it i don't know that's they're
not just the phraseology that's used in
the market i didn't come up with this
because there are drinks too i guess
that's suggesting you know anyway right
so
does that mean that um
that pre-rolls again that's the service
i mean if it's that's clearly i guess we
consider that part of loose if
it's a convenient service to do
pre-rolls and that's that that's fine
but we need a manufacturer to do that
right unless we think the our our our
stores are going to do that in the back
room somewhere
uh topicals that's definitely a
manufacturing thing
right cartridges is a manufacturing
thing and concentrates it's a constant
because they're they're extracting the
whatever they need to create these
concentrates
so
what
so are we going to say to manufacturers
yes concentrates are going to be sold
and cartridges going to be sold and
pre-rolls are going to be sold and
topicals are going to be sold
in our
we in our state-run stores
or
are we not
you know is
huh manufacturing has to happen in new
hampshire you can't import this stuff
technically
so i i don't want to confuse matters but
if if we say no to that how are we going
to track how we're going to track if if
if we are going to sell these products
in our stores
then we need manufacturers to do that
so how do we attract manufacturers if
we're not going to do edibles and
ingestibles
and not the other things
no no no no no i think you know it's a
good question and it is certainly
confusing that every state seems to have
a slightly different system of
classifying what is an infused product
versus an edible versus something else
but any way you slice it there will be a
need for
manufacturers to produce all of these
products i think pre-rolls could be done
by cultivators if the rules are
sufficient that's really easy it's just
an extension of trimming so you can't
give us an answer to that right
i'm not entirely sure what the precise
question was but i agree i would i would
agree that it's complicated and i can't
give you a final answer something we can
just discuss further on monday
i just think we need to define these
terms as to what's in and out
yeah let me let me comment on that if i
may
and really the point is what i want to
say is to agree with you
representative romney we really need a
clear definition of what's in or out
and looking through this bill i don't
find it
i don't find a clear definition
and it's pretty important given
well
given how it plays out in terms of the
state's revenue so it's directly
implicated into our job here
so
representative lange
in your amendment do you have a
definition of it so i was just looking
at mr chair and the only thing i i'm
trying to see how they're using the
definition but it just on on page 2
section
line 31 it says cannabis products means
concentrated cannabis products and
cannabis products that are compromised
of cannabis
that makes sense and in other
ingredients are intended for use or
consumption such as but not limited to
edible products ointments and tinctures
so
that's the one i was looking at that too
i can't find in the bill and maybe i'm
blind here or
too tired
uh
from yesterday and the day before but uh
i can't find the prohibition
give me one second i'm trying to find it
so
so the university part the only thing i
see is on page three
starting around when it talks about
possession limit
it says cannabis infused products
creating thc purchase from a retail
cannabis store which is defined as a
state-owned store
shall be limited
to medical use only
for which the purchaser presents
documentation permitting the use of
cannabis for medical purposes so
that cannabis infused products which
again i don't see a direct definition of
so that's probably if we have cleanup
language it's right there
because i don't see anything that says
cannabis the only thing it talks about
is cannabis products
under on page two and then three is
where it limits
cannabis infused products to be sold
for medical customers only
michael oh i've done it again
what i would
suggest is that
you start with the section in the bill
that
commands the liquor commission to sell
cannabis
and
clarify that command with reference to
a definition or definitions
it could be
cannabis
and you stop there but then you've got a
definition of cannabis that covers it or
you could say
shall sell
cannabis but not including
and then you limit
limit it
that way but um either way it's got to
be clear and maybe the lack of
definition and clarity tells us that
we've got a free hand here
because i'm not
seeing it
come across my
plate here as as clean as
it's been suggested it is that's clear
that's a good point
i'll go through it and see what i can
find and adapt accordingly
appreciate it
mr chairman thank you um uh on on page
two section seven
uh there's there is the definition of
cannabis
it says cannabis means all the part of
the plants the genes cannot whether
growing or not the seeds thereof the
resin extracted from any part of the
plant in every compound manufacture salt
derivative mixture of preparation of the
plant its seeds or its resin including
cannabis concentrate it shall not
include hemp fiber produced from the
stalks oil or cake made from the seeds
of the plant sterilized seed of the
plant is incapable of germination or the
weight of any other ingredient
compounded combined with cannabis to
prepare topical or oral administration's
food drink or other product that's part
of what we're talking about
i think it gives us a start and and then
a few more maybe if uh maybe i think
you're going to send a a
definitions over to tim wright if we can
combine that with the definitions we'll
probably be able to come up with
something good
and as long as it touches all those
kinds of things
and then right
but it does impact the red and it this
all is pertinent because it does it does
equal revenue
if we eliminate concentrates that's less
revenue
okay
representative hackenfeld
anybody else
questions for mr simons
thank you thank you
anything else that we need to take with
us
banking just speak for one minute since
they've been patiently sitting back
there oh
christy do you do you just want to just
spend a minute since you've been sitting
back there so patiently
and we'll
thank you mr chair um christy merrill
with new hampshire bankers and with me
is ryan hale um and just to be clear we
are we are neutral on the policy of
whether or not to legalize marijuana but
we are just available as a resource to
answer any questions representative lang
was kind enough to take suggested
language from us in terms of protective
language for bankers
who would like to
bank a state-run cannabis operation
so
you're okay with his amendment relative
to banking yes it looks very similar i
will just want to just double check that
but it looks very similar to the
language that we provided so that was
per our uh recommendation
questions
um
this was approved by your association
board is that correct this was approved
by your board of yes it was whatever
your structure is yeah
questions
thank you
you're very welcome thank you
so banking goes out
well state bank goes up the state bank
and the state bank goes up
anything else we want to
bring with us for the weekend
if not then we will meet again monday at
10 o'clock
and the first thing
is to take is to take care of house bill
1584.
representative aaron and representative
schamberg
are going to come up with
another amen
yeah would you get in touch with him
and tell him i
can you turn your mic on
i said maybe if
one of the reasons that cannabis is
has to be grown in new hampshire is that
new hampshire has a agricultural
presence
and brand
maybe just a little bit of money
eventually can be
go to the fares
from the sale of
in the future
thank you representative elmi
yeah i just wanted to ask if
um
rebecca vlang could take a stab at
adding into the definition
wherever it is of a approved growing
facility that it would be
within
a hoop frame
a indoor
on an indoor environment
because i think it it is just about
impossible to guarantee quality
unless we have huge numbers of extension
agents helping
yeah
mr simon
i'm sorry i forgot to address this when
i was sitting here before but i think i
can shed some some light on this
so currently the new hampshire atc's are
required to be fully indoors every
product is grown under the lights that
is the most expensive way to grow
cannabis it's also the best way to grow
high quality flower
i was in maine last week i talked to the
owner of a company that has a medical
cannabis dispensary and is also
wholesaling into the adult use they have
a greenhouse for their medical facility
they have a greenhouse for their adult
use this enables them to produce a much
cheaper
product but everything has to be
independently lab tested and that is how
from a regulatory perspective you
guarantee quality to the
end consumer now they don't have that
requirement on the medical side but they
absolutely do on the adult use side
vermont similarly
wanted to make it as possible as as
easily as possible for small-scale
cultivators to participate they've
they've adopted unlimited licensing
they have six cultivation tiers
including a very small tier that they
designed to be very accessible
and the way they did that is by
requiring everything that is sold to be
independently lab tested whether you're
the biggest grower or the small grower
smallest grower you have to go through
the same testing requirements before the
products can be sold so typically the
best products the best flour will be
trimmed and sold as flour everything
else will be become trim used to produce
oils to produce infused products and
that is how there's a secondary market
for the flower that isn't the very best
so some percentage will always be grown
indoors it'll be the high-end flower
but you can make costs go down quite a
bit and frankly if neighboring states
are allowed to grow outdoors and new
hampshire cultivators are not allowed to
grow outdoors even in greenhouses that
would be a substantial market
disadvantage for new hampshire
so
all of these products
are either grown indoors or they're
all of them tested in labs
they're all independently lab tested in
every adult use market that i'm aware of
in in every medical market except for
maine's
it's standard to have independent uh
required lab testing for all products
and we think that's just smart policy
thank you and whether it's indoor out
it's in the bill
yeah there's testing
i don't think it's i don't think there's
a clear mandate that all products be
tested right i don't see that in the
bill
there's really a lot left to imagination
and the liquor commission will surely do
it this way but
i don't see a lot of requirements that
are usually in bills like this
is it in our costs
i don't think the liquor commission
understands these things very well yet
is it in the cost i believe that if i
may mr chairman the liquor commission
talked specifically in here today to
testing
so mr chairman i think that they are
aware this needs to be done
yeah i can close this argument again if
you look under
on page five where it talks about the
regulation of cannabis it starts and if
you go to number
ten
require that part of the rule making
things they have to do the requirements
for the testing of cannabis so it's a
mandate for numbers it's on page six so
it follows on to page six on line 12. so
again as part of the regulatory
requirements and and the rulemaking
requirements of
the agency they have to
create rules for the requirements for
the testing of cannabis right
yes thank you for that and i may clarify
it does not require that all cannabis be
independently lab tested it authorizes
the liquor commission to make rules that
may require it i'll agree with that a
big difference
you'll fix that again if we want to if
that's the will of the committee is to
say that
in in instead of putting it in rule
making and telling them they have to
create it i can put in there that says
uh create rules that says test that that
testing will be done of all cannabis and
then they'll create the rules around
that
i'm sorry
like independently laboratory testing
well there's a testing there's a testing
license in here so the facility has to
light if they want wanted if they want
to be a certified testing facility they
have to get a license so what i can do
is under that number 10
just change that to say that they'll
make rules or regulations requiring the
testing of all cannabis
if that meets the requirements of the
committee
representative romney yeah i'm at um
when you mention vermont tiers so that
they have seven tiers but they also have
uh is their licenses tiered that way in
terms of
small farmer less fee per year to have a
license is that it it's your knowledge
absolutely yeah six six cultivation
tiers
and uh the license fees vary
dramatically from the tiers uh
furthermore each licensee in vermont can
get each type of license but you can
only get one so you can become
vertically integrated if you apply for a
cultivator license a manufacturer
license and a retail license but they
limited all of those license types so
that nobody can get one more than one to
limit corporate consolidation etc
okay thank you
just one more question about vermont
we're gonna
shut this place down by quarter off
yeah
so go ahead yeah i don't think vermont
has started yet they're still approving
it
yes they finalize the rules they've just
opened the initial application period
but they have approved and finalized all
the rules the legislature just signed
off on them last week i believe so most
of the details are known
any other questions
thank you we'll see you on monday thank
you very much thank you mr simon and and
to the folks in the back of the room
thank you for being here
just a reminder
um